ladies and gentlemen you have exactly
two weeks left to get your hands on this
wonderful trash taster trip and let me
tell you you don't want to be missing
out on this one
drip over and over again we know how
many of you missed out on the last trash
taste merch I mean drip so why not get
it this time around we got t-shirts
sweaters as well you don't want to miss
out on this go get it right now Link in
the description because they're never
coming back after this I said to apari I
refuse to do more merch shops unless
there's anime girls on them and you know
what they came through they came through
so what are you waiting for smash that
link in the description down below right
now to get your trash taste merch before
it's gone Joey there is an unsolved
Rubik's cube right here salivating at
the mouth just looking at that I'm gonna
mix up this Rubik's cube right in front
of Joey and I'm gonna leave it here no
the entire podcast I'm not distracted by
that because I'm too busy admiring Our
Sick new merch
foreign
this is an organic advertisement that we
have done because I like the merch so
much and I'm wearing it yeah I can't I
can't wait to wear our embroidery you
know do you know why I'm glad we're
doing a new merch drop
um so Connor has more than one shirt he
can finally wear I do need to wear more
I Gotta Wear more shirts all right
that's how it is yeah because uh you
know I don't know if you guys know I
guess we're welcome to trash taste
because I was gonna like just jump right
into it because I had something hello
like hello welcome to trash taste I'm
your host for today God and with me are
the boys whatever but so is this one
half it's 120 episodes
we're like you know how it knows it's
began I thought we were gonna do like a
[ __ ] you know a little little banter
for the intro but then I was just like
you know I I have like a segue to jump
on now that we're talking about this
sure okay
um so Connor has like everyone thinks
it's a meme but Connor wore your like
track like your previous apari trash day
shirt every for every show aside from
one right yeah
how the [ __ ] do you do that how the [ __ ]
do you get away with that how many
shirts did you pack for uh I had three
of them so I was just cycle through them
um and just wash them because you know
every single show had uh well most of
them had laundry yeah so I just did my
laundry even if I had like two two items
I would just throw it in there wasn't
wasteful of energy yeah probably but I
kept it the meme and that's honestly
worth it every time I looked over it you
it felt like groundhog okay yeah
I'm like wait so it's still day one of
the tour or I didn't do every shirt I
thought no I'm not gonna do that and
then the second sure I didn't wear it
and then after I was like ah [ __ ] really
I didn't notice it do you know do you
know what I found funny is that you know
we had like the our tour staff members
with us and everyone everything like
that and they didn't realize you had
packed multiple shirts until like two
weeks in and I remember someone on the
staff member just awkwardly asking when
was the last time you watched that shirt
they thought I was wearing the same
shirt the entire tour I was like
um well that would be gross and no I had
three and I just washed them a lot
because they're very good quality and
they could withstand water
yeah but yeah my God man I just it just
makes me want to just take you out on a
day to Tokyo to just like dress you up
take me out and put me down
get rid of him just get rid of him dude
I like that I need more clothes that are
good I just it's tough can you let me
coordinate you yeah sure I actually like
this sounds like a joey Channel video
Yeah
someone who owns a clothing brand I want
to take you out and give you some nice
clothes okay I feel like you need it
yeah here's a question how many times do
you guys buy new clothes and when do you
guys make the decision to like bin like
when do you make the decision to bend
old clothes because I'm not one to hold
on to old clothes right I pretty much
get rid of them the moment I feel like
I'm realistically not wearing this
anymore it just goes in the trash yeah
for my my rule of thumb is if I don't
wear it for at least a month or so yeah
then that probably means I'm not gonna
wear it for the rest of them how
wasteful of us yeah
um but I donate all my clothes so ah
okay I'm the complete
[Music]
[Music]
I am that guy who you open up the
wardrobe right so I remember at my old
at my old place my wardrobe was
completely full right and so I moved
into this new place like last year and
it's great because I have a wardrobe but
I also have like a second storage room
yeah that also has like a clothing rail
I'm like great I finally have more space
for more clothes and
it's like I'm like a year into living in
this new place I'm like [ __ ] both
wardrobes before now bro I I don't even
I try and have my t-shirts and don't
even take up half like a small one
actually I have I have a [ __ ]
confession to make okay so you see I've
you seen me wear this belt right quite a
lot of times it's a nice spell right
yeah I've owned this since I was 17
years old I am I I am not joking this
this is a 15 year old Bell and it's
still it's still like it still holds up
which is why I've never thrown it away
you know what's [ __ ] up I also have a
belt I've had since I was 70. serious
I think this is because you guys have no
no discernible ass cheeks that are large
because bro my belts last a year tops
before they're [ __ ] really it's bro
it's like my belts are like Atlas bro
they're holding it up and then like it
just can only last a year I swear to God
I don't know if I'm buying [ __ ] belts I
I was I thought this was the problem
I'll buy some nice belts yeah so I
started going up in the in the belt
Echelon yeah and I started getting nice
about it so I I got a belt that was like
what I thought was expensive it was like
a hundred dollar bill and I was like
that's [ __ ] expensive for a [ __ ]
but I guess if you're looking for it to
last long time yeah yeah dude this [ __ ]
lasted like six answer is [ __ ] what
are you doing to it I I I'm not I don't
think I'm doing it particularly tight
just tighter than how it would look my
pants up without a belt right so I don't
know what's going on my belt game is off
maybe I'm doing something wrong
maybe you're just too [ __ ] dummy I
think my ass cheeks are just too big I
think this is the circumference is too
much to handle Connor's Bell uh Connor's
ass the destroyer of what else it's the
shearing Force right because it's an
angled Force it's out you know it's it's
not meant to handle it I also you say
you donate your clothes bro like bro if
I try to donate my clothes it'd be like
what if what the [ __ ] are all these
sweat patches bro they'd be like take
this back
the guy I do the because in Japan right
they have they have a lot of they have a
thing called uh well they recycle the
plastic yeah yes now when you think
about that you're like oh they must be
reusing this plastic no no recycling the
plastic also
contains burning yes yes that also means
recycling yeah so maybe that's how my
clothes are being recycled this is
thrown into a fire fire oh the amount of
odor into them you put a flame to those
genuinely I I wear my most of my shirts
to the point where like I don't like I
I'm pretty sure I couldn't even donate
half of them they're so [ __ ] wait do
you 100 my boxes bro the moment I I I'm
that kind of guy who's like whole I'm
like one hole copium it's still good
enough it's still good enough and then
holding your boxes no that's a tiny
little tiny hole tiny hole and then I'm
like it's still good she's fine she's
sturdy and then literally like two weeks
later it's like [ __ ] and you're like
my lip my literally my entire dick is
out yeah my limit is like can I pass my
fist though I should probably throw it
oh no I've had some I mean we talked
about in the past podcast episode but
like I've had boxes that have like holes
like this big and I'm just like yeah
it's still good
I do take I I actually find joy in
throwing out clothes or getting rid of
clothes okay so I feel like it's a new
level in my life
I just like I should I I should throw
away clothes but I look at some clothes
I'm like maybe I could still make this
work and I just I I get you bro so it's
I have like a tearless system right of
just like current clothes I'm wearing
yeah clothes that I maybe wanna you know
maybe want to try again and then clothes
that I've like worn once and I'm like
trying to look for like a nice occasion
to wear this clothes and that's like it
just keeps [ __ ] building up and I'm
like what is I don't know what the
normal like level of when you decide to
throw away your clothes because I'm
gonna be honest for most for most of my
life the person who threw away my
clothes was my mum
yeah yeah that was because she was like
God you've not worn these clothes for
three [ __ ] years I'm throwing it out
for you and the thing is she would have
to do it when I was away from home
because she knew if she asked I would
like fight her on it
do you hoard other stuff or is it just
no just clothes just go because
I think I don't have like do do you guys
buy new clothes regularly as well
because I I like okay here's the
weirdest half my wardrobe is like yeah
who's just giving me stuff here's the
witness I remember when I was in England
and I was applying for a credit card or
something like that and they had to like
give you they you had to give them like
uh like a breakdown of your expenses
like every month right and so you have
to tell them you know how much you spend
on like uh approximation on how much you
spend on food travel Etc and one of the
categories was clothes now and I
remember thinking when I was applying
for this credit card uh when I was like
18 or something it's like why is clothes
a monthly expense is is it normal to buy
clothes like a new piece of clothing
every month because for me it's
definitely not so I was like what is
what is the normal schedule for buying
new clothes for other people because for
me it's just other people who buy a lot
of clothes yeah yeah I mean like some
some people just you know buy a new
thing of clothes every week if they want
to and they're just like yeah I'll
probably eventually aware one of these
days and then they become hoarders like
you so I remember when I was a kid
um you know like uh was it The Learning
Channel TLC yeah
but like obviously this is that type of
reality TV show has been around for a
while yeah and the UK had this kind of
stuff years ago as well wait do you mean
PBS uh no no The Learning Channel which
is the not very much not about learning
it's literally about like the My Strange
Addiction
That's The Learning Channel That's The
Learning Channel yeah TLC that's what it
stands for The Learning Channel I
check this I'm pretty sure it's The
Learning Channel
um are you serious yeah so that's how
could you like addiction learning yeah
and all those shitty fiance yeah there's
a lot as on The Learning Channel good
let alone about that perhaps you should
uh wife someone after 90 days that's a
lesson it's an education and what not to
do with your life I gotta make sure I'm
right I'm sure that's what it is oh it's
both oh oh it's tender loving care and
The Learning Channel okay
so so the point being is that I just
certainly remember when I was like 15
and this very vague memory of one of
these types of shows being on where it
was like My Strange Addiction kind of
vibe but like I don't know if it's real
my clothes for sure there's this one guy
he was like like the most British
Northern man ever he's like man I just I
just have to I have to throw away my
boxes after I've worn them I just can't
wear re-wear a pair of boxes I just want
only one time use yeah it's time for use
so they would just film shots of him
going into his car and just opening up
new pairs of boxes oh yeah it's good to
have a a fresh bag
it's just like what is this what the
[ __ ] is this he's the reason why there's
a oh there's a hole in the ozone layer
the amount of clothes throwing away and
burning
he said I remember as well on this
channel he was like yeah it's it's
ruining my life and my financials are
terrible yeah I can't afford anything
because I'm spending and he of course of
course he didn't buy like the family
pack Costco yeah it was like I need
Calvin Klein every single day did he
also have a thousand thread count as
well so he was buying he was spending
like 20 quid on a pair of boxes every
single day and he had a jet like just a
normal ass like salary there was nothing
and he was just like I just it's just
too dirty it's sort of re-wearing a pair
of boxes
disgusting but he's wearing the same
t-shirt pants socks yeah yeah are you
wearing them is he doing it with socks
as well yeah yeah he was re-wearing
everything except for boxes he just felt
like it was dirty I feel like that's
that's some weird trauma that's
literally the meme of please can you
help me uh manage my expenses food 200
rent 800 boxes 3 200 boxes all these TV
shows are like this they'll be like
they'll be like man this family is
having financial difficulties we brought
in a financial expert to sort it out and
I'll be like all right so yeah rent all
right uh yeah wow water all right food
all right so we have 900 on a hot tub
annual subscription all right sorry it's
like the the financial expert has
figured out what is going wrong it's
like I hold on this is not gonna lie
yeah we did not need a financial expert
yeah I would have done this it's just
like half the price just like buy less
boxes no
I've tried that every every every single
UK Financial thing it was like 90 of the
time it was like stop ordering take out
food it was literally it was literally
and it was like Wow problem solved wow
thanks Dr K we we have all our money
fixed well we're we're wealthy now and
it's like
what is this I'm just I'm just convinced
that like the majority of these like you
know TLC based like families and stuff
like that that you see on Like My
Strange Addiction or whatever they're
not real families no I'm pretty sure I'm
just like they they have to be scripted
what I want to know is
what I want to know is like with these
reality TV shows where they take this
struggling something a struggling
business or a person struggling with
issues they fix the issue on the program
how many times do you reckon it just
sticks like well they relapse after day
luckily luckily we have an amazing
example and the only way that we can
defensively track it is something like
Kitchen Nightmares yeah where we can
actually just see which restaurants are
open that's true yeah and most of them
are not open still if you go through the
Kitchen Nightmares restaurant list it's
so depressing put it out on your phone
like kitchen nightmare restaurants that
have closed it's literally like entire
seasons all the restaurants have closed
like it's like [ __ ] it's like okay
well Gordon couldn't help that much it's
almost as if maybe bad ownership was the
problem all along that we can't really
fix Gordon comes in just screams in our
restaurant for an hour and then he's
like [ __ ] problem solved I guess my job
here is done I have no doubt I have no
doubt some of those restaurants were
that were helped and were much better
off for it yeah man obviously that
ultimately what the TV network wants
and what the restaurant wants are two
very different yes yeah yeah maybe
Gordon wants both but I mean ultimately
we're here to get the shot
how much how much contact time do they
actually have with Gordon apparently not
that much is it just like two days or
something yes because if that I went on
this rabbit hole because I was so
fascinated by all of this right I wanted
to know everything about how this worked
yeah yeah apparently it would not be
that much it was literally he would come
in do the film segments and then leave
yeah um yeah that sounds about right
because he's like I've I've remodeled
the place to make it look more alive and
it's like no your production you know
your production what do you mean like
I've come up with new recipes and like
Gordon you're a three-star Michelin Chef
there ain't no [ __ ] way you came up
with recipes with this one [ __ ]
dingy-ass restaurant I know it's
literally it just also which wouldn't
make sense because I assume the filming
said it would be so intense that it
makes no sense that he would be Hands-On
to that degree maybe when he's there I
if you told me that he actually cares
about it I I believe that like when he's
there filming the stuff but there's just
no way they've had the time that they
need well he has to care because that's
his job yeah so it's like he's that's
kind of what he's getting paid and the
show's so scripted like yeah
so obviously there's this part there's
this part and then we have the
reconciliation and then we have yeah
owner maybe admits that he's wrong or
whatever it's just like all right
whatever so where's the part of the
episode where it says planned yeah is
there like is there like an episode of
like Kitchen Nightmares where the owner
just refuses to admit that they're wrong
or something oh yeah yeah yeah
there's much more kitchen
so there was a a very famous episode
right uh only do you even need to
explain what kitchen everyone [ __ ]
know what this is right like I think so
Gordon Ramsay fixes a struggling
restaurant everyone has seen this yeah
the little Clips make have like 50
billion views on YouTube yeah yeah so
there was one it was um the little
Baking Company right was it was it
called again uh baking company called
nightmares Kitchen Nightmares type it in
yeah it was like it I think the year
when that episode aired or when it came
out it was like the most Googled thing
of that time right this episode was so
huge because it was like an hour long
one where they were just shouting and
they never fixed anything and everyone
thought it was like fake but after like
having a lot of people go to the
restaurant this is like full legit like
these people were like insane right and
they just somehow these producers just
stumbled upon this gold mine dude I
would love that job are you I just
finding restaurants that are [ __ ] and
like just find these crazy owners that
sounds like such a fun experience I want
to know like what is the process of
finding these restaurants right I wish
I'm wondering do they apply for the show
or do they like kind of I'm guessing
people do apply for the show and they
have some kind of service application
yeah okay okay okay I remember because
sometimes they mentioned it in the show
they applied or yeah this person because
a lot of the times think initially they
weren't exactly told what the TV show
was yeah and they're just pitching like
do you want your restaurant to be helped
on camera with Gordon Ramsay yes and
it's like this is the shittest kitchen
in all of North Hampshire or whatever
it's like all right
[Music]
no one would want to eat here I'm sure
I'm sure there's a bunch of restaurants
as well that are just like so much on
the dimebrink that they're like lost for
us just be like well Gordon Ramsay came
here before it shut down two days later
you know so we got our 15 minutes away
yeah I think everyone's the worst
Italian restaurant in all of Connecticut
he's an [ __ ] he's gonna fix it I
think the best like promotion they got
for the restaurant is not like Gordon
Ramsay coming in and fixing the [ __ ]
recipes and changing a few tables some
[ __ ] is being on [ __ ] Kitchen
Nightmares right of course yeah my
favorite entire segment of Kitchen
Nightmares is when they're like they
they um obviously the restaurant is
closed and they don't they don't tell
you this but they don't also try and
hide it it's really weird so there's
always that segment where Gordon goes to
the restaurant and he wants to see how
the restaurant functions and obviously
it always it always goes wrong of course
yeah it's a disaster and the cut the
restaurant is filled with customers
right yeah but they're like customers
that have been invited because they know
they're filming right because you
actually can't just go in a restaurant
have a bunch of cameras and get everyone
to sign the waves yeah they fill them
with this thing but they don't actually
like tell you the audience that they
kind of brought all these people yeah
but then suddenly all the customers
start being picky about everything and
you're like well hold on a second I feel
like I feel like they're trying to make
this a disaster like everything has been
good and everything goes wrong everyone
always ends up fighting someone storms
out it's like yeah there is no way this
is a normal night of dining and nowhere
are these restaurants full on a normal
night of course not yeah oh that you
just remind me of like this [ __ ]
weird uncanny valley effect that I've
had with like some reality TV shows
recently have you watched like Britain's
Got Talent like Reese yeah it's awful
yeah so there's one thing that they've
added like in more recent Seasons I
don't know when they implemented this
but I remember watching Britain's Got
Talent by [ __ ] 2006 2000 like all the
way back in University
um in like the early seasons and it was
like you know I had the same kind of
formula but recently they've been like
adding these shots like these what I
would call like audience audience Vox
pops right where the talent comes on
stage and then they'll be like a Vox pop
oven like audience member commenting on
the talent or something yes I have seen
this and I'm like this is so [ __ ]
weird because there is no way you just
like you you have good audio to just
capture a random audience member someone
someone here is a plant it's like you
know you know when you see some of those
like E3 trailers and they have like the
fake gaming chatter yeah or some of the
trailers that's what it [ __ ] feels
like you know I think I think I've seen
one whereas like it was like a magician
or something and you kind of had like a
Unique Look to Him yeah they just
randomly as he's walking on stage it
just randomly cuts to the shot in the
audience of these two girls who are like
he kind of [ __ ] looks weird
and I'm like we didn't we didn't need
that yeah we really that was an
unnecessary reaction yeah reality even
like dying so they're just doing crazier
yeah [ __ ] right yeah it's it was just
it's just such a weird thing that
they've added and it feel to me it feels
it makes it feel even more fake right
because you know especially now being in
production uh seeing seeing how finicky
audio is there ain't no way you can
[ __ ] zoom in on just two random
audience members just to hope that some
one says something interesting
the one that the clip that I just
mentioned I remember I was like there's
no way this is real because everyone is
clapping in this huge room and these two
girls are whispering and it's perfect
audio and I'm like I don't see a mic on
you yeah you just happen to know to
release the camera at that particular
time it's like come on I just want to
know did I just like get a random person
here and just be like yo so I wanted to
say something really quirky when the
when the guy comes on stage okay just
just say something really quick just
comment into how you look just be mean
just me just be really really mean yeah
and then when they do the act just be
really surprised and say how great it
was right oh that was actually kind of
surprising producers are some of like
the cruelest people on this dude some of
the [ __ ] that they set up is so cool
yeah oh yeah tormenting people for fun
yeah like I mean I I've watched some
videos recently just talking about like
one of the most infamous Japanese live
streams I've oh I've seen this yeah I'm
sure you guys have seen this video as
well like got recommended for like ages
but I like they literally trapped this
poor guy this poor Japanese guy in a
room you know in a like a random number
one in the late 90s in the late 90s and
he basically had to win his freedom
through raffle tickets or raffle prizes
basically and they [ __ ] literally
started him bare naked in this room and
he I think lived in the room for like
months and months and months and months
that was it that was his name yeah but
it was like um the TV show still ongoing
not that segment because it's a very
famous comedy show yes in Japan yes and
they have just segments that um they've
just changed over the years but I mean
it's really popular yeah and I think
like the the part that like the part
that got me so [ __ ] angry right was
he was in this one apartment by himself
for months no social interaction no like
sometimes he couldn't even eat well
because it all everything he won and
everything he lived on depended on
raffle tickets and raffle prizes right
um and so after months and months and
months of living in this place he uh he
he wins his freedom right and they're
like we got the producers are like we're
going to reward you we've been in there
for months with no human contact and he
literally can't eat and by raffle
there's like mail-in Raffles like in
Japan you can win a lot of stuff for
your Raffles by mailing in like there'll
be a cop they just gave him a stack of
magazines yeah they were like enter
everything yeah and so he finally wins
this Freedom
um and then so he they reward him with
this nice trip to Korea and he he has a
fun day at the park you know they've
they film him in like an amusement park
and stuff like that uh and then they
blindfold him for his final prize yeah
and then they take him to this
mysterious place and then they ask him
to take the blindfold off and it's
another room
and then the producer just says strip
your clothes right now and as you just
see the soul leave from his body and
it's just what I'm like you're watching
this and you think I'm literally
watching torture right now it's like a
snuff film yeah it's literally a snuff
film yeah yeah Japanese game shows have
been notoriously not very chilled but
people silence hand the waivers and they
do it yeah more people agree to this
yeah and especially in Japan I feel a
lot of like comedians that are up and
coming or kind of not maybe not selling
as much or you know are open to doing
like any kind of job at this point just
to like stay relevant yeah the ones who
throw themselves into these situations
because I remember like there was a
another I don't remember if it's the
same show but there was another show
similar to that where like these two
comedians were locked in two separate
rooms and I couldn't get in contact with
each other for and I think it was like a
week or two weeks and there was one door
out of their room and it leads to an
open Paddock that has a bunch of farm
animals right and what they have to do
is that they have to survive purely off
of the breast milk of those animals that
they catch for that day
for like two weeks and there's no and
and the one and the one rule is like and
the one rule is you're not allowed to
drink water so like your food and your
like drink and everything is purely
based on a how many animals you can
catch and B how much milk you can get
out yo so someone to get the voice of
milk to another [ __ ] level man I just
I'm just imagining this and I'm like God
the the horrendous shits that they must
have just had oh God you're just
drinking milk for two weeks straight
yeah it's just horrible for your health
yeah I don't know I mean I I you know I
absolutely beg the question of how real
is it obviously if you're taking it at
face value it seems [ __ ] awful yeah
I'm sure there was some behind the
scenes stuff involved where I [ __ ] so
sad yeah
I mean with the Nabu situation I'm like
the the whole situation played out a bit
too well yeah for them for the producers
not to be like I I feel like the
producers decided what to send him at
what time because just as he was running
out of food or something he would get
like a small W like a whole bag of rice
or something and it would be like it's
like a kind of like an entire story in a
sense yeah it was weird so he was
standing like a few hundred a day right
yeah he was spending like hours a day
just like writing yeah about it it's
very interesting yeah we can't really do
it justice because yeah we're
remembering it's [ __ ] this episode is
sponsored by Harrys boys giving a great
gift can make you look really good and
giving the gift of Harry's to the men on
your list can make them look good as
well this holiday season treat a loved
one or yourself to Harry's starter set
for a better shave I know who I'm gonna
be buying Harry's Connor would you like
a Harry's for Christmas I already have
my own Supply but would you like another
Harris supply of Harry's come on tell me
why you want Harry's for Christmas it's
the only that I used the first time I
actually used it I was like all right
get rid of all my other razors it is
genuinely the best shave I've ever had I
highly recommend it but boys did you
know that the Harry Starter Set includes
a five blade German engineered Razer
weighted handle foaming shave gel and a
travel cover and yet this it is a 13
value for only three dollars but only if
you use our link harrys.com trash test
only if you use a link and boys Harry's
new holiday gift boxes include premium
shaving and grooming products in gift
boxes nice enough to go right under the
tree no wrapping required so check off
all the guys on your list with a Harry
Starter Set first time buyers get a 13
value for again just three dollars by
going harrys.com
and check out Harry's gift boxes as well
but act fast because these offers are
for a limited time with limited stocks
so again go to harris.com trash taste
this episode is sponsored by expressvpn
watching Netflix without using
expressvpn is like going to the arcade
but only being allowed to play one game
why would you do that guys come on
Netflix in every every single region has
different content libraries and if you
use expressvpn you can make sure that
you access every single one of those
libraries every single one every single
one expressvpn lets you control where
you want Netflix or other streaming
websites to think you're located so guys
the World Cup is happening right now and
you know what as much as I love the
Japanese commentary I miss the good old
British commentary oh yeah so I've been
watching the World Cup VR expressvpn on
the BBC iPlayer because I want to see
football come home okay it has blazing
fast speeds and you can stream in HD
with zero buffering and they have
servers in 94 different countries you
gain access to thousands of new shows so
don't be stupid be smart stop paying
full press for streaming services and
only getting access to a fraction of
their content get your money's worth by
going expressvpn.com trashtaste that's
expressvpn.com trash taste to get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free
back to the episode
fun fun conversation topic uh about
Japan
it's gone yay so I um I saw this article
uh and it was a Japanese article about a
Japanese thing and I I want to know your
reaction and opinion on it yeah so
there's an article
and basically a guy a kid uh like a 15
year old kid had stolen uh like a plug
extension cord like a five dollar plug
extension cord yeah from a store and his
parents found out right so his parents
called the police and called like made
him apologize and give the thing back
um and that was their way of like
teaching him and punishing him I guess
yeah because he stole so stealing's bad
and he should get arrested for it sure
yeah
um what I was surprised by was would you
reckon the the Japanese comments were
like what do you think the the overall
thoughts were on on that move uh on the
parents calling the police
yeah what do you think what do you think
how do you think the Japanese people
reacted to that okay okay first of all
question how do you react to that what
do you what do you think it's a bit
excessive
I mean what do you think you think it's
good setting an example or do you think
it's Overkill
um so the pair is called the police
right so that they found out that their
son uh had stolen this like plug
extension yeah not from like a friend's
house or anything from a store right
yeah so he's shoplifted yeah yeah
shoplifted and another if your friend
makes any better but somehow if I if I
stole a PlayStation from Joe you're like
that don't worry about it I wouldn't
call the cops
you stole it from a store right which
feels way more like oh okay yeah uh so
yeah he stole it and then they they
called the police and obviously he
doesn't get like he doesn't get jail
time or anything because he's a kid but
you know just to slap on the wrist right
yeah and get scared and interrogated for
a while yeah what do you think how would
you how do you feel about that do you
think it's a good move I feel like
calling the police is kind of like going
a bit nuclear yeah
um I would get him to return try to
return the extension core to the store
if you're doing anything else and you
know being completely being completely
honest with the store members to be like
this happens
um we're bringing it back he's sorry
yeah you know if he can don't you know
yeah we'll pay for the chord whatever
you know I feel like and then I would
rinse him when I get home yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah
yeah but definitely like at the very
least get him to apologize to the store
members yeah and stuff like that that's
right amicable if you can't
um I don't know what I would do I feel
like in in my head I see that as
them
I don't know if this is like fair I feel
like you're just kind of making your
parenting obligations and putting them
on the police like you're doing the
parenting right because you're like like
ah [ __ ] yeah scare him make him make
him feel bad about it right it's like I
don't know couldn't shouldn't if he's
your kid shouldn't you kind of install
these beliefs and then you know punish
him or give you I don't know I feel like
it's not going that far I think because
he needs to learn that he has
consequences of assurances for wrong
actions I think the least okay
I think the belt is still yeah I think
police is a little bit extreme but at
the same time you know I feel like the
parents are taking the boy to the police
you know to see to show him that there
are consequences which I think is
different from some examples I've seen
where parents are just like you know
other people should just handle this you
know teachers need to teach better and
discipline my child and stuff like that
you know
um you know because I think there's a
big difference between you taking an
active role into taking the the person
to see what the consequence of their
action is versus wanting someone else to
completely take over for you yeah yeah
so what was the uh Japanese reaction
then uh the from what I saw they were
like oh my God the parents are so brave
and a lot of people were in agreement
and the general consensus was that it
was a really Brave and really honorable
thing that the parents did Brave yeah it
was Brave what's Brave about it
I guess because they I don't know
because most Japanese parents would just
be like oh maybe just take it back I
don't know I to me it's like it's weird
because I think that you know I feel
like the police are [ __ ] better
things to do or they I'm like I don't
know about Japan but generally right
because like oh finally yeah like I
don't know I feel like the police should
do real stuff and not I mean I mean I
feel like this this might work for Japan
just because maybe only in Japan could
you imagine in the UK if you did this or
America they did laugh at you they'd be
like get the [ __ ] out of here yeah stop
wasting our time I got to do with like
actual [ __ ] yeah like apparent your
goddamn kids yeah um no I I agree though
with the whole thing of like it is up to
the parents
I think that this is coming from three
dudes we don't have kids yeah I just
think when I when I heard this my
initial reaction was like oh wow nice
wasting police times great yes no I
agree but I also read now this is on a
Reddit it wasn't an article so I take it
with yeah it's just like a
a uh I think it was a reaction no it was
a foreign couple with uh one of the
Japanese one of them is far yeah and one
of them was far the foreign guy was
pushing on Reddit be like what the [ __ ]
what is this yeah so I think it was on
it was one of the Japan reddits because
I just love keeping up with them seeing
what seeing what fun stuff's happening
yeah and um
uh this uh his daughter that was like
eight to ten years old had taken an
eraser from a store and the store owner
called the police right on the kid yeah
and the police uh like interrogated the
kid for like three hours
because they stolen eraser and then were
like taking apparently we're taking like
uh well they were like oh don't worry
though we won't we'll put in the system
but it was bad that I'm laughing we
won't send it to HQ
they were like what the [ __ ] I just got
a traumatize this you're trying to teach
him a lesson I teach him a lesson I just
wanna I just want to see the scene of
like the kid coming out with the cuffs
and the towel over the hands I think it
was like so what happened to us sorry um
so what happened that the mother made
the daughter take theater I remember
that yeah mother made the daughter take
the Eraser back to the store okay I made
them apologize like you said yeah don't
apologize get back and the store owner
caught the puck the cops
from that right and it was like whoa in
my mind I read that I was like Jesus
Christ imagine you're like oh dude I'm
sorry I'm my daughter she's you know she
didn't you know just stole it no you
know here it is yeah you're like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm calling the police I'd be
like whoa that's all that's an [ __ ]
move on the story yeah I mean lawfully
he's rightful to do so but you know
morally it's like very [ __ ] excessive
yeah yeah I just again what a what a
[ __ ] waste it's like a 50 Cent eraser
and they're just like yeah cops I mean
it's I mean the kid's got to learn
somewhere right the kid has to learn
yeah but like no I'm talking about the
store owner the kid has to learn and you
know he's not your [ __ ] kid so you
can call the [ __ ] police but you know
you can be like this is your chance to
be like a good like good A Good
Samaritan showing a good example of the
you know to the kid of if you admit to
your wrongdoings they're you know there
can be consequences but there is also a
chance for forgiveness as well you know
I'll just like that's that's that's my
take that's my take has like not
developed at all the kid yes maybe the
kid will steal and then he will learn
that this is very bad and my God the kid
will very much learn now yeah but then I
think that's too excessive yeah but then
I feel now the kid is going to be scared
to do anything but yes the guy on Reddit
was basically asking I think he was kind
of asking like hey how can I like how
can I Lodge oh yeah how can I Lodge a
complaint or get something done like it
was because I don't like they they were
like this is [ __ ] up like and I I
don't know the law is but I it seemed
even for Japan that that was not what
you were supposed to do yeah that's
pretty much that is way overboard that
was like a bro moment they literally
like apparently he said for three hours
they were questioning her and they
wanted to question her without the
mother there but the mother was like
absolutely not yeah that's [ __ ] up how
do you oh no question how do you you
found it yeah
so they made her write a confession and
they took the mug shot of how old was
the kid
oh my so wait can I can I can I read it
out tonight
it was so insane could you imagine
getting a mug shot down at six years old
I did not do this story Justice okay
okay
so it finally happened had my first
police experience and not in the way I
would have ever expected my six-year-old
daughter stole the racer from a
stationery store okay when her mum found
it around an hour later she marched her
back to apologize and the upstanding
storekeeper young dude early 30s called
the cops
and he said he's going to call her
school
he's there's a store and he's going to
call the school offer to do it actually
since he said the cops probably well
Cops show up and they continue the
forced March to the police station they
interrogated her made her write a
confession and took her mug shot they
actually wanted to do it without the
mother in the room and the mum said [ __ ]
that they said that since she's under 14
they won't be sending her file to HQ the
whole ordeal took around three hours all
girls crying and shaking the whole time
her mom isn't doing much better I know
you'll be asking for the details here
I'm not Japanese her mom is I wasn't
with them she never stole anything
before no I didn't punch the storekeeper
I didn't punch my favorite color is blue
I like walks on the beach great so I
think he was kind of asking like uh it
was really sounded sad as well I was
like the kid is okay on the surface but
the thing but that kid is scarful yeah
the kid is doing okay on the surface but
the first thing she did when she woke up
the next morning was to wash her cups
that were in the sink which makes me
think that she still feels guilty and
she's in trouble we're working on that
it's like what the [ __ ] man this story
is insane
seldom believe he has a reason to lie
about it on the other side am I the
[ __ ] so I just interrogated this kid
for three hours am I the [ __ ] I was
bored I had nothing to do with work so I
thought [ __ ] it but that dude I was
excited is my first interrogation how
how do you like this is It's just insane
sick six years old I I I can it's it's
sad to say I can totally believe this
being a real story here just because
again it's like you know we've talked
about Japan thing ever yeah Japanese
police are for the most part bored as
[ __ ] because there's barely any crime
that happens they're often joked about
being online I've seen this a lot about
being just babysitters because they
often don't yeah
do much and they kind of enforce very
odd stuff like this yeah exactly like
I guarantee because like
I feel like this would cat this could
happen only in the place like maybe like
Japan or somewhere like that because the
store owner calling the police kind of
like matches up because it's just like I
don't know what to do it's not my it's
you know I'm just following protocols
the protocol was called the police
you're six years old I do not see it I
just see a stolen eraser therefore how
do you see a six-year-old girl returning
this less than a one dollar a race and
be like you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] police
yeah maybe maybe he had like a weird
like false sense of like justice being
like if I don't stop her now she'll do
it again and it'll just get bigger and
bigger and bigger so I have to stop her
at the arrest where's like the Japanese
Better Call Saul like spin-off what my
mom calls Saul like
this child is six years old your honor
what is the kid like genuinely what is
the kid gonna take away from like being
six years old and traumatized I just
don't understand well she'll never go
into a stationary store for the rest of
her life
can I borrow them
I just like I just read that [ __ ] and I
was like what the [ __ ] dude yeah
Jesus Christ ten levels above excessive
yeah
um
yeah
I bet I don't know if yeah maybe some
Japanese people be like dude mom's so
brave the place
for taking a risk and then just putting
his safety in Jeopardy by calling the
police on a sexual I just don't I just
don't I mean I yeah I think isn't a
racer really worth it like I just I
assume I don't know how maybe that
they've had stuff robbed all the time
this was like the final straw yeah I
don't know but like it just felt like
it's like this is like not the battle
Yeah on average ADN yeah like it's
nothing it's not even a dollar it's like
it's just they're coming back to say
sorry yeah this is the kid that you
don't call that like the kid that you
call the cops on I none of them but like
the person that you should be is the one
who tries to get away and doesn't come
back exactly if somebody's coming back
there's a there's they clearly care yeah
it's clearly a [ __ ] yeah why would you
and then clearly for the most part won't
do it again so just like it's not like
it was a like a Louis Vuitton bag right
oh my my five-year-old daughter stole
the Declaration of Independence sorry
it's like no it's like this was come on
man I know that theft is like looked
down upon way way way more harshly in
Japan than than say Western uh countries
it's all crimes right not all crimes you
eat corn dude they're so okay so I
obviously there's a whole whole thing of
if it's a fine it's not a crime for the
rich right yeah that's like the and
there are a lot of stuff in Japan where
it is find where you would get prison
time and like our country or like so
like um
um like in America right drink driving
is like a misdemeanor right uh oh no
sorry it's a mission in Wisconsin it's
in there it's Wisconsin Wisconsin has a
it's very leading like in the UK and
Australia I think and yeah America you
go to jail uh even if you're over the
limit but Japan is like two limits
there's one where it's like a little oh
come on give the boy fine yeah
you can't drive for a few months I think
there's two can you look this up there's
one where you definitely like full-on
punishment lose your license but there's
one if you're over a limit you don't
really get much for punishment it's a
fine and in Japan finds on considered
criminal no they're they're transactions
yeah so so the way it works is that like
you don't if you pay the fine you're
done at the transaction yeah the
transaction is over yeah it's pretty odd
and there's a few other crimes kind of
sounds like legalized bribing in this
sense doesn't it if you subscriber like
that
officer officer it might give you an
extra thousand yen will you rub it off
the Record
it's not it's not a fun it's a legalized
bribe guys
oh my gosh
um
that's for the which limit is that is
that the one there's two limits right
there's one other thing on which blood
level your alcohol is hold on did you
say 500 000 Yen or a three years in
prison
yeah
and three is in prison okay I was about
to say if it's all yeah I don't know
who's gonna be like guess always three
years behind bars instead of paying five
grand the same if you refuse to take the
drug test okay it doesn't say specific
there's definitely like laws in Japan
that aren't punished as severely as
other countries and there's stuff that
is punished way harder than other
countries yeah like anything with
children for example
Japan is uh just like a little slap on
the wrist everywhere else it's like
you're going to jail yeah yeah I I
there's I mean I don't know the specific
specifics of it but obviously even like
um I mean not depressing but it is very
depressing I think it's important to
mention it yeah of course there's no
um dual custody laws in Japan so if you
divorce it's often like you know it's a
bit bit sus and also like domestic
violence is pretty bad here and it's
very underreported because a lot of the
times they're just like well nothing we
can do yeah guys there's no evidence
guys so you didn't do it yeah um and it
kind of sucks I mean obviously the
Western countries like that as well but
I know that certain punishment for
things and again off the top of my head
I can't remember which ones but I know
there's certain crimes that should be
punished way more yeah like I mean like
sexual crimes aren't taken nearly as
seriously as in other countries
you know it's pretty it's pretty sad
it's [ __ ] up yeah yeah well going
going back to the kid though yeah I'm
just like wondering was there like ever
a point in your life that you have like
internalized as like a point where
you're like oh this is bad I should not
do this thing again you know when you
were young or something because oh yeah
like you know every parenting has like
different like disciplining methods and
I will never ever forget my dad's
disciplining method okay okay I'm about
I'm about to call you out Dad it's
because I might take notes and I'm like
uh I might
I might actually uh learn from you
because I remember you know
you know there's a lot of disciplinary
message methods people have talked about
when they were a kid you know especially
in Asian countries you know you gotta
get a little slap you know a little
little spanking you know maybe maybe you
get shouted out or something my dad has
never raised his voice to me when I did
something wrong as a kid he never raised
his voice to me at all instead I
remember this one time uh I rarely have
seen my dad angry I can't even remember
what I did wrong right but I did
something wrong that's disappointed my
dad a lot and made it made him angry and
I remember instead of shouting at me
instead of like instead of like giving
me a smacking or whatever uh he would
just lecture me and teach me and refuse
to let me go anywhere aside from listen
to him lecture me and I swear to God
this lecture lasted around like two
hours
two three hours and I remember I did
this thing at like 11 p.m right I was
tired and he was like no you're not out
to go to sleep you need to listen to me
lecture you right
and he will just like in the calmest of
voices right not anger or anything he
would just lecture me but just refuse to
let me go anywhere until I had you know
fully listened to him and I and for some
reason uh like after that point I was
like I'm never angering that again I
would rather just get shouted up or
[ __ ] suspect for like five minutes
and then it's done my punishment is done
but now I know if I piss off Dad I'm
wasting three hours of my [ __ ] life
you're listening to a one-man podcast
for two hours yeah and I and I remember
it was it was like we were it was there
was a point where I realized I had
shared trauma right because I remember
this one time in Thailand I was my dad
is like the eldest sibling of this
family right and he has like a pretty
big family uh and I was hanging out with
one of my uncles I was hanging with one
of my uncles and we were just talking
and I remember
um he was like one of the younger uh
younger younger brothers of his family
so I remember talking about oh you know
when when I was young my dad would
discipline Me by lecturing me for hours
and then I remember my uncle just shut
up for like two minutes and you could
just see like a wave of memories coming
back
yeah the ptsc just comes back and he
just like yeah he did the same to me as
well
that's such a power but this isn't
miserable yeah it was it was miserable
but yeah it [ __ ] worked because I I
knew I knew afterwards that that was the
that was the traumatic experience in my
childhood not not really traumatic but
that was that was like a core memory for
me just to be just to be like okay what
I did was wrong I'm not gonna do it
again I'm not gonna piss off that or
anything like that
um yeah so good on you Dad just uh I
might take that I might [ __ ] so I
definitely feel like yeah because my my
parents were kind of I was like very
rarely they would actually like shout
yeah because like I feel for a kid and I
don't know if it's just me but like for
a kid there is nothing more I guess
traumatizing than not seeing an angry
parent but seeing a disappointed parent
you know what I mean like an angry
parent is like it's like okay they're
angry they're scary but it's usually for
a short amount of time like you can't be
angry for hours right you can't be
shouting for hours yeah but you can be
disappointed for days
sometimes weeks depending on the parent
and like that [ __ ] just lingers right
every hour that you're in the same house
as them and I feel like as a kid that
[ __ ] just hits you so much harder yeah
than seeing your parents actually be
like pissed off or like yeah something
right so I feel it's like yeah it's a
very I mean that's a tactic my parents
used that [ __ ] worked on me as well and
I'm like you know what I might use that
man you know this the scary part is the
less they say you know if there's
something you've done something and then
and they just say like one or two words
and then go away you're like
I'm gonna drop my kids off at the the
police station
I'll pick you up tomorrow just drop me
off the police station this morning he
just sits them down and you just like
put in a number and you just show them
it's like I'm about to call them they
had that America TV show right where
they would send the kids to
prisoners to intimidate that God that
[ __ ] is so we just get prisoners to
shout at them it's like so funny I don't
know is this really a good idea it's not
like a trauma machine it's like what is
the line between traumatic experience
and learning experience right some You
could argue that's a very very my
favorite some people rule their Empires
my favorite thing about that show though
is just like it clearly like people
didn't people clearly don't look at that
show and look at like you know kind of
the the the depth I guess parenting yeah
and look don't look at it as like the
pillar of parenting because it's just
one of it's like you know they could be
like 14 year old kid is like uh Brandon
you know did drugs and you know stole an
eraser from a stationery shop or
whatever right and then there's you know
a huge [ __ ] dude with like tats and
neck tatts and everything just like
shouting being like you don't want to
disappoint your mom right and then it
just costs to be like uh Jose killed
three people and I'm like
oh this kid doesn't learn I'm just like
you're gonna have to say that again you
really have to think about it I'm
curious what the parents who are
watching this think of uh the punishment
the the yeah parents of trash taste how
do you how do you uh how do you like
your parents
let's have three dudes who don't have
kids talk about parenting and how to do
good parenting that's always okay listen
I don't know how to do good parenting
but I know what not to do I figured some
stuff out yeah I know that I'm not
taking my kid to police station
I feel like their memory is just not
gonna be there it's not do you remember
anything from being six years old
I would if I was taken to the police
station that's I remember that yeah I
mean I don't know anything else I mean I
I remember a certain points very very
early on
um like I've told this story before but
I remember like the first time I lied
which was uh what I believe I was like
five or six years old because I was just
I remember I remember the feeling
yeah literally it was that it was that
yeah it was that it was literally like
The Invention of Lying moment yeah it
was literally I was like five six years
old and I'm gonna be like I'm gonna do a
Pro Gamer move I'm gonna do something
I'm gonna do a devious and move right
now what if I don't tell my mother the
truth that my mother of course
immediately caught onto it and I
remember that because I was like oh my
first attempt at lying was a failure so
it was like your mom's just like you
[ __ ] knew yeah yeah so by failing my
first life yeah it instilled in me for
the longest time that every lie is a
failure
being a kid and your lies [ __ ] suck
like why why can we not just think
through [ __ ] for like two seconds okay
I'm having a trash taste moment I'm
having one of those things but I can't
remember if I've told this story or not
okay right where I lied to my mom about
my hair no I cut it I don't think so you
haven't all right so you know
dumb why the [ __ ] did I do this so you
know when you you sleep right and you
wake up and you have bed hair but when
your hair's short right sometimes the
bed hair is like persistent yeah no
matter how much water you put on that
[ __ ] it won't go down yes yeah it will
just stay up yep yeah and so I had this
and I was like this is annoying the [ __ ]
out of me I look dumb as [ __ ] I must
have been like hey and so I had this
idea I was like it's not going down yeah
I gotta just cut this [ __ ]
like cut your bed here so I just had I
had a piece of bed head that was like
this and it just wouldn't go down after
I put a little water on it would stay up
and I'm like what the [ __ ] so I took a
pair of scissors run in the mirror and
and then [ __ ] idiot yeah yeah I
realized that was when I realized
cutting hair not the move no I realized
I looked at the side I was like oh
oh this is the patch basically because
that's how Hair Works
and obviously
obviously my mum comes home yeah and she
looks at it she's like what the [ __ ]
happened what did you do and I was like
um
um um I closed the door on my hair and
it ripped it out
and she was like what and I was like
yeah she was like let's try it
here we go we go to the door we go to
the door it doesn't even fit like you
couldn't even if even if you by God had
willed this it couldn't happen at least
not how the door was like free like this
wasn't possible and she was like what
actually I was like I cut it because I I
it was sticking up and I couldn't get it
out she's like you're an idiot she's to
immediately marched me over to the
barbarism was like just cut it all off
it looks [ __ ] stupid fix it sorry it
was super short then after because I
[ __ ] it up it was a dumb idiot yeah
because like I was a kid I was like man
parents are so good at uh telling when
you're lying you know maybe I didn't
realize I was just a [ __ ] dumb kid no
I was I was bronze rank or they were
like messed around
I was climbing still I I didn't know how
to lie yeah you tried to go on for your
old and they just have a counter right
it's like this will get him and it's
like oh okay it's like the L.A Noir
moment where it's like look at the
subtle facial features to tell if
someone is lying did you did you ever
play a game boy late into the night and
then they would try and come in your
room yeah of course of course get really
good at hiding
my go-to was like I would I would put it
in the pillow but then obviously they
learned that I was like yeah you'd keep
you'd keep thinking of new ways where
you could hide it I put it in my pants
yeah like stand up boy you're like what
is that what is a square shaped penis
uh I just [ __ ] myself
you're five years old that's not what
you're packing this badly man
packed like a USB did you ever did they
ever like to try and find it oh oh yeah
of course see I they didn't initially
but then they weren't convinced that I
wasn't sleeping yeah yeah and they were
like he's hiding it somewhere and they
would just maybe do like a [ __ ]
search in the middle of the night they
stand up we're gonna check the bed check
out of the mattress check everything I'm
like damn they're good
she's good can't figure this [ __ ] out
did you ever have like an experience of
like going to like one kid's house whose
parenting was obviously like very
different and had like oh yeah oh yeah
and you just like your mind would be
blown by the [ __ ] oh yeah they could get
away with it the kid who like just had
everything yeah like you just got all
the stuff he wanted yeah that [ __ ] was
like going to his house was like
Disneyland yeah it was like we had to
play Crash Bandicoot and Spyro now if we
the that kid in my life was like their
parents I guess their dad was just like
super chill yeah like especially I mean
not to say my parents like super strict
or anything but this these pairs are
like a little bit too chill yeah right
to the point where oh this kid's gonna
be like a problem child all right
because I remember first time I went
sleepover right again this is around the
time where like I'm [ __ ] you know
hiding from my parents with this game
yeah in the middle of the night and I
remember like dad comes in tucks Us in
he's like yeah you guys you guys good
you got water and everything and then I
I [ __ ] remember this moment where he
like as he's closing the door he turns
around he goes don't play Game Boy for
too long
I'm just like what your dad lets you
play it
amount of time bro my no no dude that's
not fair yeah I love my mom but she
knows that I complain about the dumbest
[ __ ] growing up and she always just she
always hates it when I mention it on the
podcast she's like it wasn't that bad
you make it sound so bad
we wouldn't I don't know if you are you
at the same thing we were not allowed
branded products like it's just like so
if it was like if there was toothpaste
you bet we're getting like Tesco's own
if it was if it was crisps it you no way
in hell are you having Walkers yeah it's
Tesco's or Little's own yeah everything
was like the store brand version of
everything because my mom believes she
she might she just cannot fathom she's
like they're all the same okay listen
there are some products I'm with you on
that right yeah some products are the
same branded but get the [ __ ] out of
here if you think that little crisps
taste as good as Walkers they just they
flat out just don't because I do this
this one time I had these days like they
were like snack snack invites or some
snack of these or something was a [ __ ]
name the packaging looks God awful and
they taste like ass I opened up this bag
and there was just a brick of like ash
it was like coagulated crisps that had
been burnt to death and it just came out
of the bag and it was black and it just
got Ash of like crisp Ash all over my
desk and I was like wouldn't happen with
Walker's bum yo mom is literally the
epitome of way of walkers at home
it's literally just a bat I kept making
like I was such a little [ __ ] kid I was
like that she's like I don't want a bag
of Chris yeah I want a bag of Walkers
yeah because the kids at school always
had the Branded snacks and they were
they were so fired yeah it was so good
of course yeah because like for me I was
like exactly I had exactly the same
thing but with technology yeah right it
was it was like oh God you have your oh
yeah you don't need it
because
I remember I remember the first phone I
got because like back when mobile phones
started to like go introduce right
everyone had the [ __ ] Nokia 3310
that's right right and I was just like
damn I wanted to get it not to get a
phone but to play Snake yeah Mike was
like gold the coolest [ __ ] games on
forever yeah and I was just like so
disappointed when I caught my first
phone and it was like a like a an unbra
I can't even [ __ ] remember the brand
it was like one of the cheapest [ __ ]
phones you could buy in like phones for
you or some [ __ ] like yeah and I was
just I remember they had like
they had games on it right but they had
this like the it was it wasn't even
snake it was like a very very cheap
knockoff of snake and it was it was pure
copier me playing this being like guys
I'm having fun this is kind of like
snakes it's Cobra it's Cobra guys
I I my mum was very much against getting
me any of us a mobile phone yeah and she
she didn't for a very long time and then
she eventually caved when pretty much
everyone else had them had one and my
mom was like well like I said I don't
want to get bullied so fine but yeah but
I'm not buying because back then you
have to top up right as well you had to
put like yeah oh yeah yeah you didn't
text because taxi was expensive yeah and
you had 140 carat limit LG 20 days you
like fit everything in yeah if you
didn't you were [ __ ] so yeah I mean it
took a while but I got it and yeah all I
did was just send funny Bluetooth videos
to each other and we'd have like the
what was that one video that went down
like the meadow it was the [ __ ] car oh
scary scary videos
[Applause]
that and for some reason that was the
funnest [ __ ] ever
we're so [ __ ] dumb now they get to do
now kids probably have everything I
can't believe I was entertained by that
dumb [ __ ] I know I remember oh my God
you just unlocked the memory so I
remember like it was my second ever
phone I got and like you know
it was the Motorola Razor
[Applause]
on the side and it like goes like that
Joey's parents wealthy no no no so I'm
so I'm the oldest you know sibling right
I have younger sibling right but like
you know how like it's very traditional
where it's like if you have an older
sibling right you usually get their
hand-me-downs for a lot of things right
I didn't have an older sibling to get my
handy dance from I got it from my dad
so as I had this like shitty [ __ ]
phone I don't even remember the brand of
it my dad had the Motorola Razor and
then when my dad was like I'm gonna give
myself a [ __ ] Blackberry yeah you can
have this [ __ ] shoes with the
Blackberry back in the day where like
the coolest [ __ ] they were the coolest
[ __ ] I don't know why that was like the
hype but I remember I got the I got the
you know the Motorola Razer right and
this was around the time where you could
start to use like you know custom
ringtones all right this is like the
[ __ ] back in the day where it's like you
could like you know download ringtones
or like you know if you figured out a
way to like kind of like uh you know
pirate ringtones right if you put them
onto your phone you were like the cool
kid at school yeah and I remember I was
like at home and I was just like surfing
around I'm like man oh friends around me
have this [ __ ] cool [ __ ] custom
ringtones it sounds so cool I want one
as well so I start looking it up yeah
and I and I remember I found a site that
was like you can get get this the Super
Mario Brothers theme as a ringtone on
your [ __ ] Motorola reason I was like
just ten dollars this is it and so I
fill in some [ __ ]
and I have it on my phone I go to school
the next day and I'm like check this out
show them ringtone they're like yo
the [ __ ] a month passes my dad storms
into my room oh no no and he's like son
why do you have a two thousand dollar
phone bill no what oh
it turns out the thing that I clicked
was a pop-up ad
and uh they were taking money from my
[ __ ] parents account for like three
or four weeks and like I don't remember
the exact amount it was but it was like
it was four digits and my dad was so do
you have to pay it uh yeah no and he was
like where the [ __ ] did you find it I
canceled it and I'm like the 2000s yeah
and I never got the biggest and I had
the biggest beating of my life like I
was like
I think the bloodline would end there
yeah
[ __ ] I remember like I don't know how we
got resolved because obviously I was
very young with it yeah but like by the
time I realized I said I was like oh
them Super Mario Bros
you paid two thousand dollars for the
Super Mario Brothers ringtone it was
like at least a thousand dollars oh my
God yeah so um yeah don't don't do that
is uh is the thing but you were the cool
kid in school
three weeks yeah I was the cool kid in
school that had the Super Mario Bros
ringtone man and kids were like yo where
the [ __ ] did you get them I'm not
telling them
all right watch have you been scammed
yeah you have I was I was I was thinking
about the same thing while I was like
have I ever been I'm trying to recall if
I've ever been scared yeah I've never
been scammed luckily that was the only
time I got scammed thank God but uh yeah
that was uh scary
ah God because I remember the first time
like I I was also a kid right I didn't I
didn't well even the main target is kids
yeah and elderly people yeah pretty much
that's a two scam yeah yeah it's like I
could not even perceive like the the the
like the even notion of being scammed
and I remember we uh oh my God this is
like unlocking a memory right now it's I
I remember we got like some spam mail
and now I realize it's spam mail but at
that time I had I got this mail in and I
remember it's from it was from Reader's
Digest right I don't know what that is
it but it was I remember it was a comp
the company was Reader's Digest and it
was it was uh a male that said you have
uh you have passed the next stage of
this raffle that you've entered and I'm
like what we've entered a raffle yeah
yeah and we'll pass the next stage I'm
like what oh mother we are about to be
rich and it was just like we because
like
so so I saw like the prize money and I
saw that we'd enter the that we'd enter
the next day surprise money was like
thousands of thousands of course yeah
something like that
um but there were this this raffle this
competition was like several stages
right and I remember the second stage I
only had like a few more participants
left and to get to the next stage you
had to buy one of their books
that was like 25 pounds or something
like that and I was just like mother
we've already had zero investment in
this raffle we have reached the next
stage may I procure your credit card for
just a moment while I buy this other
mother you know what they're saying you
got to spend money to make money so uh
I'm sorry and so I think my mum like I I
don't know I think my mom just went with
it one because I just seemed happy and
two just as a learning experience for me
right so I buy this book this [ __ ]
book gets sent to my house and of course
I wish you got a book huh yeah yeah I
got a book about from Reader's Digest
about the [ __ ] architecture of
castles in Edinburgh so I'm sure
so we get the book yeah then we'll get a
note with it saying congratulations
you've reached the next stage of you've
been successful in reaching the next
stage in the raffle uh to reach the next
stage you have to buy two books and I'm
like oh my god
mother we are too far in now to say no
okay there are only a few participants
left and I think I think she let me go
for about two more stages
and I was just like Mom we're too deep
into this to like give up now Mom please
how many books did you end up with like
[ __ ] five or seven yeah she got seven
books about lovely castles yeah
and then she and then she was like no I
just
gone you're a [ __ ] idiot okay do not
do this again do not fall for this again
okay and I was just like what do you
mean they were lying mom we're almost
there we're this close we're this close
to winning the grand prize and that was
my first scam that I ever fell for damn
um hey at least you got seven books yeah
I got seven books out there so one of
the main reasons you know people that
scams are so successful because people
don't talk about it when they have been
scammed there's a lot of Shame around it
yeah people are too ashamed to admit
they've been scared oh yeah yeah which
makes sense right because if you've been
scammed out of a significant amount of
money where it affects your life then
yeah you know you would feel stupid you
know that's valid but you know you still
should talk about it because the main
reason they keep getting away with it
because people don't know about it yeah
dude I okay they've been countless
occasions where between the ages of like
16 to even like now I've like there have
been some emails that are so goddamn
convincing and good yeah and came at
like because obviously they send these
emails out in Mass yep right yeah and
obviously every now and then they'll
send you an email at the exact right
time when it you just you you're like
huh you know like for example like an
Amazon refund scam or something yeah
maybe you just hit the refund button and
then a mass scam was set out just by
happenstance right yeah yeah and then
you're like huh I guess I have to claim
the money now yeah that's weird so you
kind of fall for it right but then
obviously the more you look into it yeah
I've nearly fallen for scams like that a
few times I remember there's one where
it was like sent to do with um uh I I
just submitted my tax refund pretty easy
to figure out right yeah figure out
April or whatever yeah in the UK and it
looked really convincing the website was
really legit everything looked good I
typed in most of my information it
hadn't hit send or anything and I
thought hold on a second let me go back
and have a look more at this email in
depth and so all that like you know the
easiest way to tell is sometimes the
sender yeah has a [ __ ] email yeah but
even then like there was that one
YouTube scam that went around for do you
remember the Scandal yeah I remember the
scam where it was like it was from like
you Google uh something at google.com
yeah yeah yeah and if somebody's from
google.com uh that's normally like the
actual Google services yeah and for some
reason YouTube allowed a Google and
YouTuber allowed this to happen where
they were like your AdSense is going to
be terminated and that's obviously like
wow this is that's [ __ ] up this is
this is something that is very uh
pressing and it would the way that they
had worded it was something something
along the lines where it sounded
believable because I fell into that
category of whatever they were saying
what the [ __ ] I nearly fell for that one
too I was like on the Google messenger
chat talking to this [ __ ] weirdo
trying to scam me yeah nearly fell for
it but didn't damn it's hard man no
matter how screwed on your head is man
you can they always find they're just
getting more and more they're right the
right scam at the right time can you
could fall for it like you might think
you're like Ironclad and you'll never
fall for anything but yeah just the
right timing I'm like oh you could be
cool well like YouTube has a [ __ ]
massive problem right now with I don't
know if you guys the bots on like every
reply for every [ __ ] comment it's
like it's always the first reply and
it's always you you know
yeah it's always you but usually it's
like slightly misspelled
please
profile pictures like oh yeah that's
probably him yeah this video is
sponsored by messy guys have you heard
about vessi absolutely I have because
I'm wearing them in literally everything
if you look at any pictures of recently
I'm always wearing Messi's that's not a
joke we [ __ ] love this Connor only
buys one pair of shoes and they're
goddamn verses Joey loved vessi so much
he wore it to my wedding I am not lying
that is true I wish we were joking but
boys have you seen my brand new pair of
vessels right here look at this boys I
gotta admit vessels are probably the
best everyday shoe I've ever owned the
waterproof is extremely handy and
they're durable and the breathable
material is just awesome they're also
really easy to clean as well hell yeah
they are you know guys it's coming to
Winter now in Japan and we're getting a
bit more rain that's why it's so
convenient to have the 100
waterproof shoes from vessies plus did
you know guys vessies is made out of a
material called dimetex do you know what
that is it is a dual climate knit
material that keeps you cool in the
summer and warm and cold the weather it
doesn't feel like it should be
waterproof but it is gentlemen and best
of all they're really lightweight wow
amazing vessies are the perfect gift for
under the tree and for your feet check
out their holiday sale at bessies.com
trash taste get the style and size you
want now before they sell out if you
missed the sale use code trash takes for
15 off your entire order this episode is
sponsored by crunch roll crunch roll
games launched its newest RPG the
Eminence and Shadow master of garden
this anime RPG is based on the popular
light novel and new anime television
series The Eminence in Shadow guys did
you know that is actually an isakai of
course it is okay why you're so happy no
no it's not actually it's actually
genuinely good it's one of the best
Easter cars airing this season because
you know what it parodies itself it
knows not to take itself too seriously
the game features key characters from
the novel and manga including Shadow
Alexia Alpha Beta and the rest of the
main cast from the series you can enjoy
high quality graphics and scenes
directly from the anime Dynamic action
with fully animated skills and
team-based call combos multiple PVP
modes and Co-op raid events you can
decide the ideal team composition from
the various roles such as tank attacker
and supporter to create the perfect
balance for each challenge encountered
by logging in every day you can earn up
to 2 100 Phantasm gems hi guys don't
forget to join us for the holiday
Rhapsody event starting on December 2nd
the game is available worldwide except
for East Asia Belgium and Netherlands
unfortunately and is available on IOS
and Android and coming soon to Windows
so if you want to check out the game for
yourself then click the link down in the
description below and dig a crunch roll
for the sponsor of this episode back to
the show you know what's so funny that
you mentioned
um uh the
Edinburgh Castle stop so I think I did
this video all right so obviously
there's um there's been a bunch of uh
sponsors there's a few of them that are
on YouTube a lot you see them all the
time you can become a Lord oh yeah yeah
I'm not gonna name this because I want
to get in trouble yeah and there's
actually a ton of websites that do this
you know they're like hey if you if you
buy a thing for 60 bucks you get a one
foot plot of land yeah you're now a lord
right and so I was like I was like that
doesn't sound right
it's like my British sense
that doesn't quite sound right so I
wanted to do this video I was like I
actually want to become like get a title
right so I started looking into it more
about how how one goes about it right
and it was interesting because I you
know tldr
um the way that the laws work in
Scotland is that you you can't transfer
one square of a one square foot of a
land to someone that's not that's too
small and you can't even even if they
they say they do you don't actually own
that land it's it's a dedicated souvenir
plot so you know they're kind of saying
hey yeah you own this land in our heads
in our database but like legally whoever
bought that land still owns it because
you can't you can't transfer land like
that it has to be transferred wholly
yeah um also they change the laws on how
titles work so yeah in Scotland you can
you can actually still get titles but I
believe it's only like um Baron so you
can become like you can be like a baron
of uh high water or something yeah
that's it depends on the name of the
place and stuff you can actually get
those titles because those are titles
that have existed before and so they
changed the rules where you can't it
used to be where the the title would
transfer with the ownership of the land
right but now that that's not how it
works so you can't transfer the title
with the land you can only buy the title
off of someone else and then there's no
guarantee that you can actually get it
recognized even if you buy it off
someone it's really weird
um I'm not 100 on all the legal legality
but it seemed extremely complicated and
if you actually want to get one of these
titles
um there's a few ways you can do it you
can actually buy a title but it would it
would be somewhere in the range of 100
Grand yeah that sounds about right which
would make sense because they're very
limited right and people want these like
Rich [ __ ] want to be like the
baron of slog water yeah
and there's another whole thing where
you you can actually get a title if you
own a historical piece of land in
Scotland yeah and then you have to
submit it but then also
even if you own this land you still need
to be of it was something along the
lines of you need to be of someone of
notable stature and of of good standing
and Merit yeah you can't just be some
random dude buy a plot of land and
submit it you know verified on Twitter
you need to be verified and have a
Twitter blue eight so this whole system
is like extremely complex and they don't
even I'm pretty sure from my knowledge
they don't even give out Lord titles
anymore that's not like the only way to
get a lord title is to be born into it
right this so there's very few there's
less and less yeah so I think from my
understanding and again I didn't look
too much into that part but yeah it's
literally I think generational has to be
gifted to you by the Yeah round but they
used to sell them back in 1920. which is
actually when they used to trade hands
the most and then they stop that so you
can't do that anymore right so pretty
much the yeah there's pretty much no
real hey you can definitely get one it's
very very I again I'm not an expert this
is like two hours of research you pretty
much cannot get one let me just say like
that you can get it very very very very
very very difficult you can get it but
999.9 people cannot get it right so
ultimately I just thought about this
thing and I was like
damn this thing suck you pay like 80
bucks
somebody right oh
look you're our Lord which is Authority
yeah you are and they I mean fair if you
look at all the fine print and all these
websites they do say it but the
marketing for a lot of these stuff and
the way they get like a lot of
influences and more stuff to push it is
they're not like that they say yeah you
get to you get a one square pod like no
you don't yeah you do not you cannot go
to the land registry and say hey I own
this one square foot plot of land in
Scotland isn't that also similar to the
services where it's like you can buy one
square foot of the Moon as well yeah
that's [ __ ] that's like the Moon the
Moon in space counts as like
international waters right yeah
right now so you know it's just like I
don't know I just thought about it I'm
like oh man I don't get why people still
promoting it when like obviously it
wouldn't make sense obviously you can't
be a lord
obviously this is not how it works well
we we know this because we I guess we
grew up in like the UK right so it's
just like something sounds sucks because
there aren't that many lords in the UK
yeah but yeah yeah and I guess also you
could argue well no comments for the
novelty it's for the fun of it and it's
like what just spend five minutes and
make a stupid certificate
the whole thing is like it's a great
gift give it to someone it's like well I
mean I don't know about that like is it
really yeah you know a lot of them they
maybe have some claims like I'm not
trying to call them out I just think
that I just don't get why this is a
thing I just don't understand how it's
big yeah because I see it quite a lot
it's every YouTuber promotes it and I'm
like just what the [ __ ] this is garbage
again I'm not having names don't get in
trouble
um there's a lot of them and there's
some of them are like oh well they want
to offset it right so criticism that was
like well we plot a tree and it's okay
fine maybe you do and it's like I I
don't there's no way to verify yeah I I
don't know if you do yeah you know even
then quite the you come into the
question of like oh I don't know I don't
know how is that is that really helpful
is that like I could just go and plan a
[ __ ] trip yeah ice cream
what if you are supplant it yourself let
me let you do it yeah like pull them out
being like okay I own this land you
can't defy me by the way let's not get
into carbon offsetting that's a whole
bag of water a can of worms that we're
not even gonna get into because that's a
whole other thing that is questionable
the best but yeah I just I just for me
it's like every now and then spons some
sponsors like this come around on
YouTube where everyone seems to be
promoting them and it's like
there's anything wrong with it they're
not doing anything wrong I'm just saying
like I'm like fine I just don't get it
to me I'm like what is this no I get it
I get it especially it's hard especially
if it's like a new product that you just
you because this is like a something
like this is a very weird product right
and sometimes sometimes weird products
some of them can be legit but some of
them just don't make sense at all it's
yeah it's it's weird it's a gray area we
I don't [ __ ] know we try to like take
on as much small ships that I'm not
trying to get sued by the way
I'm just saying I I think it's not very
good yeah I mean that's why uh we don't
promote them yeah I think yeah and and I
feel it's like especially like the
pressure is on for creators as well when
they see other like maybe notable
creators or like the shiromatics and
they're like well if they're getting
sponsored by this many creators must be
legit we're we're not above uh taking
stuff that is backfired on us right
we've taken stuff that we've maybe not
liked in the past right I think every
YouTuber every Creator learns the hard
way of course yeah you know I just it's
not that I'm I would never give a single
credit [ __ ] for promoting it because I
just think that's the game
um I just I'm just shocked at how
widespread it is right and I'm like this
seems like such a niche thing that is so
obviously not true I'm like I just don't
understand I I it blows my mind I don't
know yeah again I'm not trying to call
anyone out I know any YouTubers in front
of them bro I don't give a [ __ ] it's
yeah it's part of the game I'm just
that's what it's going back going back
to the YouTuber scam thing yeah the
YouTuber comments again thing I've got
an interesting email the other day all
right so
one of my fans saw that uh saw that
there was a scammer on my comment
section like you know had reply to every
comment saying you've won X or you have
won a raffle or something like that so
he decides what if uh what if we try to
what if what happens if I try to pursue
this and see and see how deep the rabbit
hole goes that's right yeah so uh so I
get this email just like detailing what
like the messages he sent and the
messages that he got back and everything
like that so there was this guy
impersonating me on one of my comment
section it was it was kind of like a bot
and uh the bot just said you have won a
PS5 please contact this yeah you've
please contact this email for more
details right uh and so he doesn't he
doesn't send me the entire conversation
thread he just looked at the highlights
yeah he sends me the highlights of just
so if they get to a stage where he's
talking to this person on WhatsApp right
yeah if you're on WhatsApp you're being
yeah yeah yeah so so this guy who's
impersonating me right he's he
he doesn't even name himself gig hug so
it's my profile picture and everything
right yeah but the name is the gig up
oh he took your email bro how are you
gonna let him get away with it
so it's not giving it's the gigguk the
actual game holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I better
take the seat up
I've already taken the anime
but like it gets it gets interesting
when you know you get it possible he
plays along for like a little bit and
then he just kind of calls him out just
being like this is this seems like a
scam I'm I'm feeling a bit nervous about
this now tell me if this sounds like me
at all
um you don't have to doubt the process
I have vowed to God never to cheat or
let anyone down on this and I have keep
this promise for so long without
disobeying the Lord Our God that sounds
like you yeah
this is like this is monk can't speak is
this please tell me that's an all caps
it sounds like it needs to be in all
caps okay okay Carry On and it's just
like beginning to get agitated because
it's an insult Tome Me by suggesting
this is a scam then then he goes
please pay to these methods as soon as
poss as soon as possible Bitcoin deposit
oh my God
zelly I don't even know what Zella is
and it's just and it's just saying I
mean I'm doing this to encourage my fans
out there to achieve their dreams and
also encourage them with a PS5
if you don't me then you can go I can't
force you to trust me
what I will stand for to achieved been
unreal
wait could you repeat that could you
repeat that lesson okay what I will
stand to achieve to been unreal been
unreal yeah God I want this to be a copy
Pastor so bad I want this to be a new
copy Pastor well I will stand to achieve
being unreal what the [ __ ] does that
mean are they sending pictures like
family or something yeah the [ __ ] is
this they're sending pictures of like
fans who have won this PS5 basically but
I think it's just it just looks like
someone's Ebay listing basically
so uh who whoever whoever went down that
rabbit hole You you were the Giga Chad
for the day oh my God I did people who
waste scammers time yeah yeah you're the
true heroes just seeing scammers get
enraged just I mean it makes my makes me
makes me smile yeah do you doubt me do
you doubt me being unreal
I swear to my heart I got our Lord and
savior God Lord this is not a scam
are you doubting us
I'll tell you yeah
on WhatsApp I don't know yeah because
yeah it's it's it's weird because like
people will always find new innovative
ways to scam but it's just like and then
there's this [ __ ] and then there's this
well that's the thing like a lot of
these scammers like we've talked about
like Jim Browning before and how I was
exposed like scammers in India and stuff
like that but I'm just like
I don't know too much about it is
they're just like not enough laws
preventing this stuff in that country or
is it just enough enforcement or enough
enforcement I think generally like the
enforcement is lacks and you know in in
other countries
um yeah some some areas police can be uh
you know they look the other way if you
give them a little cheap payment or two
right I think a lot of places they
struggle with you know because these
places make so much money yeah so it's
hard to you know to get the government
to keep taking them down and also they
to be fair they they do get taken down
fairly often but then they just move
like it's really easy to just make this
operation anywhere right yeah just get
an office space with PCS boom you're set
up yeah and you probably make enough
money to cover any of the relocating
costs yeah yeah it's tough I guess so
easy money easy well like
how many times have you been like have
you ever like talked to someone who's
like phoned you on like like a scam
phone uh well I don't know what they're
called like that's cool scammer or
something like I mean I used to do a lot
of videos calling them oh yeah you did
didn't you yeah and they were just
getting raged but like they're really so
dude they're really good at knowing when
you're not gonna like bite say just
block your number right if they even
have a feeling that you're not like
participating they just so you that's
why you see all people who call them up
on Twitch and stuff and who make content
they do they really play the long game
they like they are on like kid Boger if
you've ever seen his stuff he's on calls
sometimes for like eight hours on one
call just [ __ ] with them like leading
them on the entire time right and then
finally at the end they get that big
payoff yeah he finally reveals he's been
[ __ ] with them yeah and they lose it
and it's like hilarious because you're
just like the dedication is unreal right
but dude I didn't have that mine were
always at two minutes because they
realized I was [ __ ] with them right
like right away and they blocked my
number so I had to keep making new
numbers constantly and then calling them
back and then they would just hang up
right away eight hours away who's this
guy again yeah his stuff's really good
okay you've Definitely Maybe seen one of
two videos and you recommended he's
really funny really good at it he
pretends to be a grandma with a voice
change
I think I have seen I've seen Clips so
that's pretty convincing like yeah yeah
yeah
um so yeah he does that for like all day
on stream [ __ ] is unreal it's Jesus is
nice it's insane yeah that's an easy
eight hour stream man yeah honestly it's
kind of crazy it's just making itself
it's awesome I mean anything that you
can do to waste these dudes time and
then hey you can also get paid off of it
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah man I
won't I want the uh the amount of people
getting paid to [ __ ] over scammers to
outweigh people being scammed yeah
we're so far away that would be a
perfect Society wouldn't it yeah yeah I
don't know I mean like yeah it's
um it sucks I mean hopefully the the
they get better in forcing the laws over
there yeah fixing it that sucks but you
know the people who live there also hate
these [ __ ] like they yeah yeah yeah
yeah I've got a local population so many
people local people just be like these
people do not represent us they actually
give them a bad name yeah yeah exactly
exactly right America is really bad as
well I know every American friend I have
they're like yeah I got like four scam
calls today it's like what yeah yeah
what yeah in Japan you got zero it's in
the UK you maybe get one every now in
the UK you get like okay the the
weirdest thing I find is like the scam
calls where it's not even a person on
the other end yeah you just get an
automated message you just get an
automated message right you have one A
PS5 so okay here's the thing though
right that obviously to any sane person
or any normal person you're like this is
[ __ ] dumb almost not gonna call this
up but in their mind if somebody Falls
for that and they call back this is your
perfect candidate to scam yeah because a
[ __ ] stupid ass robot just told them
they're going to jail and they're
believing it right so now this is like
perfect this is the exact kind of person
who will then give me his bank
information yeah yeah so that's the
problem is that we often think it's like
and that's where the shame comes into it
right is that it's so stupid in in our
mind that you could fall for this that
then these people feel so ashamed they
don't want to say anything and they
don't want to get help or have you know
or admit to it so you know there's that
cycle where I think people need to be a
bit more sympathetic towards people get
scammed I think
um because I just feel like if it's
going to improve in the conversation
around it's going to improve because
nobody talks about it nobody talks are
they I nearly fell for a scam yeah no
one wants to admit that they well nearly
fell for something so I feel like the
dialogue needs to be a bit more open
about it yeah yeah I mean I I can't
remember the last time I fell for a scam
but I remember it was it was it was a
phishing email
um kind of kind of very similar to you
and then I've realized it was you know
some moments where you you do something
and it's like me instant immediately
immediate immediately regret like yeah
like playing chess you move the queen
and you just immediately realize you've
landed as soon as you like Let It Go
yeah that happened to me as soon as I
press the submit button to like my
password and emails and luckily I S
because I submitted it because I
realized it right away I managed to get
time to like change everything like
right there and there
um because God forbid having my username
and password is something that is very
you know as as my job has gotten more
and more on the internet my username and
password has gotten only more and more
secure you know yeah of course as it's
going on yeah man I you imagine you
spend your whole [ __ ] life uh being
smart you have all these passwords that
are rock solid and then this [ __ ]
company just leaks all your information
anyway yeah passport number full address
you're like oh [ __ ] all right well
they didn't want to pay for more
security yeah changing identity I guess
yeah so there's been a few cases where
like full-on like full passport House
address have been leaked yeah yeah was
that was it the insurance database In
America which one leaked like
tens of millions of like passport
numbers house addresses full-on
information yeah wow you really couldn't
have uh really couldn't have been just a
Cinnabon account or something it had to
be had to be the one that really
mattered come on man come on yeah and I
feel especially as well like in Japan as
well like that it's just like the call
scammers especially like have you heard
of like stories about like the call
scammers oh yeah yeah like the ones that
like Target old people and stuff yeah
they're [ __ ] horrible because like
it's called the me me scam and it's
essentially how it works for the most
part is like uh you know these like
younger dudes like you know probably
around like hours you definitely sure
about this in trash days yeah yeah well
I've talked about trash taste but like
yeah they call up these young guys uh
call you know up these older people and
they just go oh to me it's me
um I'm in a bit of a situation right now
I need you to dump in some money and
it's unfortunate that these old people
just think like oh well if they're
comfortable enough to just say it's me
yeah and they sound young that must be
my grandson yeah
yeah I'm like okay you know I'll dumping
some money and it got in and it became
such a huge problem in like the late 90s
and early 2000s yeah like there was like
millions millions of like elderly
people's money just taking I'm surprised
any of these banks will transfer
anything bro this yeah it takes like a
year to do that that's how you know the
maybe dedicated that's why banks are so
slow now because they're like how do we
know
yeah
it's like it's not a whole job a
business part of a culture yeah it's a
legitimate transaction you're making or
did you scam this off an old person we
won't know I'll never tell I'll never
tell
yeah
it is depressing it is but hey [ __ ]
scammers and uh if you spend your time
wasting a scammers time you are the real
Jeep you are the real hero you're the
one song Heroes yeah one scammer time
waste one like
since we're like now back in Japan and
you know it feels weird actually having
like a weekly schedule but being able to
talk about things that we're not gonna
be releasing like five months in the
future you know it's only it's only like
we're only two weeks behind nowadays
we're talking about current events I can
talk about I can clown on Twitter and it
won't be like horrendously outdated when
this comes up man I had a trip to Kyushu
with Chris and uh man people are so
chill in Kyushu I feel like they're
definitely way more chill than up north
yeah yeah I feel like The Vibes people
are just so friendly yeah down south
Miyazaki everyone was chatting every
time I went to a store or anything
everyone was very chatty really nice
it's just Good Vibes because she's so
fun how are the tourists there I don't
see any tourists in Kyushu oh okay okay
okay so we we went to get the um uh
doing this video we had to go on the
bullet train to get to this point yeah
and it
we there was like so didn't see any
tourists in Kyushu yeah I saw like a few
tourists International tourists that
were in
um
in like a a very Scenic Place takachu
Gorge or something what is it takachiko
takachiho Gorge takachiho Gorge uh it's
a beautiful beautiful Gorge yeah that
really nice gorgeous there's a lot of
tourists there yeah that was a very big
tourist spot yeah yeah that was in place
I saw Taurus the only other time I saw a
ton of tourists is like I didn't I keep
forgetting this is a huge tourist spot
yeah so we're on the bullet train
no tourists next stop no tourists next
stop no tourists stop and Hiroshima dude
oh yeah dude I I've never seen so many
white people
I've i i as as a as somebody who's lived
here bro I I've never seen that many
white people get on a train at once like
it was like they all there's all the
white people came on single file the
whole time for about like a good like
two three minutes yeah no Japanese
people I was like holy yeah yeah that's
crazy I guess now that I'm thinking
about it you guys came at a time where
it was right before the pandemic so you
guys have an experience like the full
normal Japan I didn't realize yeah a
tourism Invasion a huge of a tourist
destination yeah I didn't know I'm funny
obviously I know people want to go and
see the memorials and yeah all the
history behind that but I didn't realize
it was like like I saw more people
getting on that train that did in Tokyo
I feel kind of bad now because
um like we've talked about on trash
tastes so many times like Japan opened
up the borders open up the borders right
and then now that everything's bustling
and everything's like busy again I'm
like man [ __ ] all the tourists man they
ain't the real ones but they don't know
the struggle man the frustration I think
that Ghana has is that it's annoying
when because you look like this and you
look like this and you look like this
yeah everyone just assumes you're a
tourist yeah which is fine but sometimes
you're talking Japanese and then they
refuse to talk Japanese back to you yeah
but like we briefly touched on this last
week and I would like to say as a
disclaimer yes that does make me a
hypocrite
because like I I just realized yeah
there's a few things right some of my
like some some of the spots I used to
like like to go to like and have like a
little bit of peace and quiet and stuff
like that now it's just like overrun
like some of my favorite restaurants
like it's it's
how dare tourists enjoy things just the
little things you know now when I want
to go to some of my favorite restaurants
before I was like yeah like there was if
I wanted to book a restaurant there was
like zero chance it would ever be full
or rejected and how dare restaurants be
like having a bustling business now and
not cater to my exact needs of when I
want to eat what the [ __ ] is up with so
how Japan how dare Japan finally we have
a thriving economy
I mean obviously very minute complaints
overall I'm pretty [ __ ] hyped that
serious about it feels more alive Japan
but we went to we went to Golden guy
yeah and um golden guy I love golden guy
I feel like it's got a certain Vibe you
can't really get anywhere else so I
think it's a Cool vibe
I mean I hadn't really gone much outside
of pandemic yeah now because most of the
time it wasn't open yeah now I so I no I
was in like I'd only really gone a lot
during the later half of the pandemic it
was great because there wasn't many
tourists and it was chilling and I've
been to Golden guy before as a tourist
and I forgot how tourist heavy golden
guy is so golden guy if you don't know
what it is it's basically this like I
don't know it's it's got like a 100 200
300 some insane amount of bars packed
into a tiny Alleyway system and it's
like there is
tens and tens of bars on like a 20 meter
strap and they all hold maybe like four
to six people Max yeah sometimes even
less yeah and we were there the other
day and oh my God the amount of times
you got recognized it was so awkward
because golden guy's tiny right so it's
like imagine there's four seats in a bar
and then like three maybe like tourists
or fans who recognizes they try and come
in and the owner's like bro what the
[ __ ] there's only one seat get out and
we're like we're like oh oh God no now
we're being a nuisance because people
are trying to come in and sit with us
and it's like no you can't come in
there's only one seat stop stop it's
also it also doesn't help that because
these bars are so small a lot of them
don't have doors yeah so people can just
kind of walk along and like look at lots
of places and they're like taking
pictures of us from outside the bars and
stuff which is fine like we don't really
care but like we're just like oh we
don't want to be in nuisance for like I
felt bad for the boss the bartender yeah
it's more like the bartender because we
didn't want to like be a nuisance to the
bar like the bartender a lot of them are
very quiet yeah Chill Vibes yeah luckily
look the the bar that we went to the
bartender was fun looking I'm having a
good time yeah I was like hell that's
hilarious what's that I actually love
going there a lot to speak Japanese and
kind of try and improve my terrible
Japanese yeah fun for that but I don't
know how much how easy that'll be yeah
it's just it's it's not so much bad as
is just a mentality shift right because
For the Longest Time Japan had just been
the place where you know you you can
just you didn't have to like think about
getting recognized or something you know
you didn't have to like that wasn't even
like a thought in your mind you're just
like oh this is just normal and now
especially going to like heavily
touristy places like golden guy or other
places like that you like your mentality
has to switch to be like oh I mean anime
convention mode kind of where you know
you kind of like we're ready to take a
picture yeah yeah you're kind of like
maybe maybe someone here will know me
maybe not it doesn't matter it doesn't
you know I mean I would still argue that
it's still not as bad because for the
most part you know Japanese people if
it's a full-on Japanese person like they
won't know who you are
again I don't mind it's just different
like it's it's like I said it's just
mentality in general I'm really happy
that things uh feel like they're slowly
being more the city feels alive again
yeah it feels like stuff is slowly yeah
it's crazy to think that it took this
long but like even bars are being a bit
more you know uh being a bit more lively
and yeah a bit more and it's kind of
it's cool to see yeah just how like one
announcement just kind of changed the
game yeah it's it's it's like I I
complete like I complained last week
about you know taxi drivers you know
refusing to speak Japanese to me but I
will say like taxi drivers also seemed
way more enthusiastic now yeah yeah
they've they've seen way more
enthusiastic and way more like talkative
and stuff like that and yeah I don't
know it seems like not just like the
tourists has reinvigorated the city but
even like the locals you know you go to
the restaurants and you go to businesses
again you know they you know they seem
way more I guess alive there's been a
real big struggle right now because
they're they're short on
taxi drivers now oh really first need
more taxi drivers they need more uh
staff for hotels right apparently
flights are like fully booked oh yeah
into Japan because people are just like
I'm going yeah I waited three years yeah
and like you know it's it's pretty crazy
now and but like think about it in one
sense that the biggest
um foreign tourist in Japan is is China
yeah and China they can't leave yet yeah
yeah so it's gonna be so we haven't
actually experienced
this is just the first wave you know we
haven't met the final boss yet this is
phase one of the boss battle guys it's
interesting though I will not I will say
not only are flight prices like tripled
yeah even more in some cases because
they were like they were pretty much
like free yeah uh hotel prices in Turkey
I've noticed I've gone up for sure yeah
they've gone up quite a lot I'm not
surprised by that um like way more than
I'm used to now I have to like
recalibrate how much I think hotels are
in Tokyo because the demand has gone the
same yeah
um but they still have quarantine hotels
really do they yeah there's a i because
you can you can tell which hotel is
quarantined because one it's an apple
hotel and two you'll see it's like
cordoned off at the front there'll be a
security guard outside right and they
still have them right and it's kind of
like oh didn't realize we still needed
quarantine hotels I suppose we do only
we did yeah I don't know interesting
yeah but I wonder I wonder why if the
hotels I want that I wanna the
government must be paying an absurd
amount of money oh I'm sure these hotels
to want them to keep being quarantine
hotels yeah yeah because like like now
now that everything's busy and bustling
again it's kind of like I've realized
there are some places I don't want to go
to as much anymore like I like
yeah I mean I haven't been there but one
place
one one place I have been to is a shibia
oh yeah and I I
forgotten how busy it gets right because
it's like because I remember when I when
I was a tourist visiting here I was like
should be a such a cool [ __ ] area you
know it's got so many bars and it's just
busy in Boston it's because you know
there's better areas now yeah yeah and
like now as a local it was still all
right to go to when it like when you
know the country was closed because you
had space and you had Comfort but I
remember like this past like two weeks
I'd been to like Shibuya three times and
like after the first time I'm like I
[ __ ] hate people I I think I hate
people right now I just like
yeah no no I've noticed that it's like I
I went to Shibuya last week and like it
was like 2 p.m on a Thursday yeah and I
remember like during the quarantine it
was like you know there'd still be
people of course because it's Tokyo
right but you know it's like pretty
quiet you know considering that I I also
experienced Shibuya before the pandemic
as well and now I went back and I'm like
I can't see the road
like I'm standing oh you get to [ __ ]
uh
it's like it's like 2PM on a Thursday
there's like 400 people on this side of
the road another 400 on the other side
like where are you all from where were
you guys during the pandemic
well so combined with the yeah and then
combined with the tourists yeah
obviously tourists right and then yeah
you're saying Japanese people now are
way more comfortable going out yeah yeah
so that's been going up yeah dude if you
come to Tokyo as a tourist and there's
more than like four of you bro it's so
hard to not like to just turn up to
restaurants and stuff now you have to
book yeah and it sucks because some of
them you have to call up in Japanese
it sucks so if you don't have that one
friend who can do that for you you're
pretty much just limited to where you
can it does suck if you don't have
someone or know someone who's Japanese
or are able to speak Japanese you get
very limited with options in terms of
yeah you don't realize you're limited
right yeah I mean I mean yeah actually I
just because I realized this because uh
when I was when I was walking to the uh
all that we were I was meeting some
people in in Shibuya I remember looking
around uh no it wasn't shibia sorry it
was uh where did I go again I think I
think it was like near Shinjuku okay
right uh so I was meeting I was meeting
a friend at the bar and I remember
walking it was like very very bustling
and I remember there was one restaurant
there was one restaurant you know you
normally see Japanese people lining up
for a restaurant right and you have to
like wait outside and stuff like that so
this one restaurant was like people were
lining up for this one restaurant but it
wasn't Japanese people it was all
foreigners and I looked up and it was
itchy Ron Ramen
and I was like no no no no no
pains me every time I see it I've never
lined up for ichironment
it is not lineup worthy I was like
clearly not trash today's views you know
clear clearly this is the one thing
we've warned you guys again so I can't
start it right past those people with
confidence knowing fully well none of
them will turn around
and it's a very popular uh Ramen chain
in Japan that's very popular with
tourists but you can get each one
outside of Japan as well yes you can
what's the point okay do that I like it
sure all right is it is it the best
ramen ever no would I line up for it
certainly hold on I think it tastes good
though
I like because you can make it spicy
that's about it yeah it's a five it's
it's fine it's a five out of ten it
ain't a 10. yeah it's okay I mean to be
fair it is hard to find good ramen
places because as well people on reviews
for some reason Japan are super [ __ ]
brutal with Ramen they yeah yeah yeah it
is hard to find a Ramen place above 4.2
like I don't think I've seen one for a
very long time well it's almost like 3.8
yeah but it's also because like again
like there's this kind of subculture in
Japan of like Ramen elitists as I like
to call them where they're just like
they got their job or just hobbies to
just like anytime they have free they go
to a [ __ ] new Ramen place they try it
out and then they just tear that [ __ ]
out right yeah and it's of course with
ramen places you're not gonna find that
one place that everyone unanimously
likes you know obviously with Ramen some
people like to show you some people like
the Miso something yeah the saltwater
and it's so hard to dictate so it's like
just go in just like don't even look at
reviews in my opinion with ROM unless
it's like a two yeah then obviously
don't go in there but I have the uh sort
of opposite story to what you mentioned
oh you're in um okayama station which is
kind of like I'm sorry yeah how do you
even describe
Transit Hub yeah um for shinkansen's a
lot of trains stop there and uh that's
why we were there we were like well
let's get let's get dinner so we're
looking around the station and we were
gonna go outside saw those giant
restaurant massive right huge could
probably fit like
100 people yeah pretty big right
no one in it no one everything else was
like pretty full yeah there was like
nobody in this restaurant
and we will flash this place twice and
later on we walked past again like two
hours later and there's one elderly
couple sitting in there eating right so
and this thing looked pristine like I if
I didn't know what it was I would have
walked in there and gladly have sat down
and been like this is pretty really nice
place yeah what do you think the food
they served was
it's a Japanese dish
Japanese what do you think is a Japanese
dish that some not even like some
Japanese people want to eat
and they had a whole giant ass
restaurant for it
thing think about an obscure type of
dish oh is it obscure no I I mean I
haven't seen it often yeah um it was
intestinal Hot Pot what's that what's up
and I was just like it's like because
she's like no we're absolutely not going
in there so yeah it's just intestinal
Hot Pot I actually like that okay would
you would you like but I would not I
would never be your first choice it
wouldn't be my first choice and I would
be sus as [ __ ] if I saw a multinari
place that big it was huge with no one
in it it was it was so big for like what
I thought was a even for Japanese
standards it's like you rarely hear
Japanese people talk about this being
their favorite type of food right like
there's a lot of other stuff I would I
would look at that and my first reaction
would be someone's died in that
restaurant someone has died from like
badly like preserved you know food bad
dishes
yeah yeah yeah so yeah it's an
intestinal hot pot yeah
um and it's actually really nice during
the winter but it's uh but but also
carry out though would you ever choose
it over a normal Japanese Hot Pot no no
you're not
you're right I get it I get it yeah it's
like that's like a once a year thing for
me yeah if that it was just odd how I
it's I don't have an issue with it
existing and being intestinal Hot Pot
I'm like oh how what they eat intestines
it's so gross I know they do that
normally I was just surprised at how
large this restaurant was dedicated to
that because that's quite rare yeah
because normally it's like they're a hot
pot dedicated that have much maybe have
one of the items but like only
multiple best food ever oh my God
okay I was in okayama
she said it's the best food ever [ __ ]
right off dude no listen I've had I've
had I've had the the cow intestine stuff
yeah at Chinese hot pot it's fine I
wasn't I I'm not like a fussy eater I
feel like I refuse to eat it I just
think that like there are a lot of
people who like it yeah yeah very easy
like people who are like that's my face
yeah there are some certain foods that
I'm fine with eating but I would never
go outside
it's not the chicken feet restaurant you
know what I mean like can we just can we
just have a chicken restaurant that also
has chicken feed why are we specializing
in this why is it also specialized in
like the one thing where it's like yeah
yeah
and you know it's yeah but it's a
polarizing and also I wouldn't like it's
like going to a restaurant that's like
oh we specialize in celery it's like oh
not sure if I I like celery I don't know
if this is just mine yeah there's other
dishes that I would like I don't know so
we just went to a Yakitori place in the
end yeah it was fine
you can get more to there as well if you
wanted yeah yeah that's really weird
yeah I don't know I'm curious actually
no you know what I shouldn't get
curiosity get the best of me because I'm
probably gonna get food poisoning and
then Chris wanted to go to an Irish Pub
we're into an Irish Pub inside really it
was so awkward whenever you want to go
to an Irish bar no he's just I don't
know you want a proper drink okay she
said they serve pints British pints
British Pines oh okay
[Music]
Chris any amount of money to stay in
that restaurant I think Christian would
stab me rather than going how did you
get food poisoning again
I'm sure it's safe I'm sure it's fine
it's just I was because it looked brand
new really like nice really clean really
like well kept really nice branding lots
of spaces I was just kind of like
maybe it's like maybe it's like Ultra
expensive it might be but again why if
you're Ultra expensive matsanabe which
seems like a very nice food why would
you be in a train station that's true
that's normally trained not to there are
some good places to eat in train
stations in Japan but it's normally like
the very yeah very affordable very
middle tier kind of fast because a lot
of the time people are in a hurry right
so it's never like really classy
high-end fancy places so you feel like
if you're going for that kind of Market
you kind of would maybe Market towards
yeah yeah that's true I don't know and
again it made sense that the only people
I saw in there were one couple that was
very elderly one elderly couple that's
it
empty I've never met young Japanese
people who are like my favorite foods
mailing mailing doesn't get no she said
it's nice I bet she's [ __ ] she's
supposed to be contrarian
no she says
she said he's the best food in Fukuoka
[ __ ] off that's what she just said in in
so there's a place in uh Miyazaki which
has the best beef in Japan that is way
better I'll take that thank you very
much
oh yeah because you went to a place that
surfed like what was it like
award-winning like the beef Olympics
right yeah so uh this I'm sure if you
watch Chris's video about it uh Japan
has the beef Olympics because of course
they do they do this with a lot of
produce actually yeah and every three or
four years they have every I don't know
how it works I assume every city brings
their beef to the table they judge which
one's the best and and Miyazaki the
prefecture has won like the last 15
years yeah to be fair it is fun and it's
it's it is good it's so good right um
and yeah we had this course meal that
was insane it was just like it was a
Nobel Prize so there's Nobel Prize
winners and this is the meal they gave
them and I was like thank God Chris is
paying man the first dish came out on
this [ __ ] caviar and I was like thank
God this isn't my video I'm not paying
for this holy [ __ ] I've never had caviar
before had it you had never had calories
why the [ __ ] would I eat caviar when
would I have had it it was [ __ ] like
there must have been like one [ __ ]
[ __ ] fats meal you've done where
they've just like added it and added it
yeah like a tiny amount no no no no
never had it before I had it and I was
like this is the most meh thing I'd ever
tasted yeah um I mean did you have it by
itself yeah oh well that's why yeah it
was it was all right it was fine it just
tasted like this tasted like it
shouldn't cost this much actually okay
so in Japan right they don't have like
the same uh what's the word
uh hmm feelings
towards certain dishes and animals that
we have in the west right right right so
I went to this uh a friend of mine
invited me to a course meal and this
very very fancy restaurant all right
it's like a business meeting in Tokyo in
Tokyo right and I didn't know anything
about it I just knew that they did like
uh really nice uh Fusion food or
something I don't know and um
there's a lot of weird foods that I've
never had uh I and there's a lot of
stuff that I haven't had because I've
heard it's awful and cruel like I've
never had whale have you think have you
had whale I've had it once yeah right
it's disgusting I've never gone out of
my way to get this stuff I'm sure you
didn't guard your way to get it either
it's just like obviously in Japan even
though the rest of the world is like we
will not whale Japan is like
no and there's a lot of places in
Hokkaido that's openly sell well stuff
and it's very normal right you know it's
a different cultural thing and is it
wrong it's for debate you know I think
it's it's kind of [ __ ] but it's
whatever my personal opinion it doesn't
matter it's not my country so
go to this restaurant and we're having
these courses and again I don't know
what's coming I can't read the menu
someone kanji dude I don't know what's
coming up but everything's been good
okay yeah everything has been delicious
and it's like
to the point where I'm like oh this is
going to cost too much [ __ ] I'm gonna
have to pay for this you know and it was
just like a client thing that's not what
I climb someone's wanted to take me to
some meal and yeah
so sitting there and then the next meal
comes out and it's like it's like steak
and it's like oh it's so good and it's
like and then the next dish was it was
like a beef cheek in total soup and I
was like
I've never had Turtle before but I've
never had but it wasn't the turtle I
wanted I was hoping for the extinct
turtles
yeah I wanted the extinct Galapagos
giant tortoise unfortunately this was a
common tortoise so then I just felt sad
because I thought about like the Finding
Nemo Turtle
yeah yeah it was like a turtle sauce and
I felt like oh was this do we turn
that's a good thing I feel like eating
Turtle I didn't know how to but again
it's in front of me I didn't know what
it was and I was just like I just ate it
and then like oh that was Turtle I'm
like what
apparently it's really good for your
libido
I don't know that's that's like every
other like that's everything
[Applause]
it's like ingredients it's totally
common to eat support yeah it's common
in Asia but not in the west try we don't
need it at all right
what team am I cheering for here I'm
like Yay no no we don't right it's
because common and soup's right in Japan
soups and like uh yeah and like Nubians
but that wasn't the big boy oh the next
it gets weirder okay dude and this is
where I was like no why did you bring
this out what the guy brings out next
stop I felt so bad he brings out he's
like all right next dish we have shark
fin oh
no no no
because I know because shark fin is very
cruel yeah right A lot of the times they
grab the shark they just pop the [ __ ]
fin off right back and they can't like
swim properly so it just dies yeah it's
[ __ ] it's such a f like [ __ ] I was
like this is awful I didn't know if I
knew I was gonna get shocked I wouldn't
have [ __ ] I wouldn't have agreed to
eat at this restaurant yeah I didn't
want to eat the shark so
we get the food and I'm like well I may
as well try it right because it's in
front of me have you ever had it no
never no this is your first time right
oh wait where the [ __ ] I don't even
know how to get shock in the UK If I
wanted to have it I don't think it's
possible yeah I think it's pretty cool I
never wanted to eat it right so I take a
bite and I'm like wow for all the
suffering and all the anguish this
tastes like [ __ ] yeah this tastes so
[ __ ] awful it's extremely boring it
tastes like nothing I just and in my
head I'm like I'm trying to get angry
I'm like this this is what we we kill
these [ __ ] things over just this part
of the fish yeah and we don't use
anything else and we throw it back in
for this and it costs like a million
dollars for a [ __ ] fin what the [ __ ]
we have failed as a society at least
with the giant tortoise there was
records claiming how delicious it was
and how how useful the water sack was
yeah you said we used everything we used
everything in the chords what is this it
was [ __ ] and so
God I was just so annoyed the whole
dinner I was just pissed off well I
think it was just like the unfortunate I
didn't know right I don't know I mean it
was it's also like the unfortunate
circumstances that shark fins I mean you
say it tasted like [ __ ] that's fine
because it's like people didn't eat it
for the day so it's like a ceremonial
thing yeah it's like a ceremonial thing
for sure so it starts getting so [ __ ]
it's extremely it's like Fugu right it's
like puffer fish it's just extremely
Bland expensive and it's purely just to
say you've had it yeah
having having puffer fish it is not
worth the Decades of training you have
to go through as a chef to become a Fugu
chef and I'm like are you seriously
telling me that
spontaneous
ly I still have a chance I could die I
just I just think when did we ever be
like you know
Shaman is pretty good eh you did like
when did we have a stray away from the
normal fish who are these [ __ ] who
are making this the hype around us boys
get this sardines yeah pretty good who
the [ __ ] pretty good who the [ __ ] is
doing this [ __ ] with the sharks and the
[ __ ] puff officially just give me a
[ __ ] Fried Chicken
someone someone was like you know what
the salt and pepper ain't doing it for
me I need a new spice paprika no give me
danger or give me suffering that is the
best yes you literally pay out the ash
just for danger yeah that's literally it
yeah just just honestly probably eating
like a whole Domino's Pizza is more
danger to your life than the fugu ever
was you know what I mean like the
cholesterol risk is probably way higher
yeah and it didn't take the pizza chef
ten years ago I just
as human beings we're just so [ __ ]
weird and why are we obsessed with this
[ __ ] I just don't get it yeah like I
would I wouldn't have a problem with
eating like a weird part of an animal if
you've also used the rest of it anyway
yeah if it wasn't cruel you know if it
was killed humanely and stuff like that
and you know if you actually make use of
the animal yeah that's why like you know
I like how like the Japanese use like
you know animals like cows or like
chickens or like fish for example of
every single part of the app yeah right
we don't let anything go to I realize
the irony [ __ ] intestines
okay okay listen I wasn't shocking that
[ __ ] out hey hey hey I better eat it
listen I've eaten it before it's fine I
just wouldn't get a restaurant yeah
before you [ __ ] tell me double
standard I'll eat everything I just
won't be happy about it a lot of the
time all right yeah for sure and I'm
firmly of the mindset of like I I'm
willing to kill every animal I I'm
willing to eat yeah yeah yeah same here
but also it's interesting because the
whole the cultural differences right of
yeah animals that they're willing to eat
of course horse very uncomfortable to
talk about because people don't like
talking about how the fact that Jen uh
Japan Japan is for a horse why are you
going to do Jam like that it's available
normal [ __ ] bar and you just there's
like horse Sashimi that you can get as
well
yeah there is there is like dedicated to
horse yeah yeah yeah very odds yeah
that's a very that's one that I find
that when I mention it on like streamers
if you have really tough time getting
over that one yeah yes yeah yeah when
you hear like shopping that's the silly
thing that other people do in other
countries
what they're so cute again we've spoken
about this before it's all branding
horses are cute that's why we get sad
about it and sharks were cute you'd feel
sorry
I mean as long you know it's they also
have bad PR you know [ __ ] Jaws like
Jules bought shark PR like through the
[ __ ] dirt and you know if if sharks
could sue yo [ __ ] Steven Spielberg
better be like sweating man he ruined
shark images for decades no centuries
even yours does not represent us
how dare you this is a stereotype I will
not stand for this there's actually a
good question well obviously chickens
are farmed in like giant things like
yeah I I get that all right but at least
I'm not [ __ ] throwing it back in the
water and drowning enough to take its
feet yeah yeah exactly I don't know yeah
I mean at the end of the day right it's
like it's always it's hard to police
that [ __ ] because it's like oh people
always throw out like that yeah the
culture you know Play Con you know be
like what we've been eating you can be
as picky as you want with this and go
down any step you'll be like well you
threw away some fries you're so wasteful
you know [ __ ] you yeah I hate you it's
like where do you draw the line then in
terms of like trying like animals you
know I
I all I know is that you shouldn't
[ __ ] chop a part of the animal off
and throw back in the water and let it
die then we can all agree on that yeah
it's like it's like if I eat an animal I
want to eat and and I want them to
utilize the most as much of it as much
of the animal as possible so that like
there is little to no waste and no
suffering and no suffering you know if
you want to go deep into that rabbit
hole you can go really deep and it's and
you know the hot stuff you can see
online is horrible yeah
um and that's how vegetarians and vegans
also I want to sleep at night so yeah
yeah exactly exactly yeah wow what a
really fun way to end this cabinet look
at us look at us guys look at us so that
was fun uh not doing that again yeah and
don't eat weird [ __ ] if you don't have
to yeah yeah don't even be curious I'm
telling you right now you can do [ __ ]
yourself for me and if you come visit
Japan please try other Ramen rather than
Rich ichiran okay it hurts yeah it hurts
when I see a line outside of each other
don't do that what was the one what is
the common uh Ramen chain that uh people
go to in Japan uh like not tourists like
locals
is pretty good all right
um uh there's a lot of it
on there right yeah
and sober in general just like some of
the cheapest and also best tasting food
you can get in Japan yeah honestly but
uh hey look at all these patrons though
oh they feed every part of the animal I
hope
shout out to the vegetarians eat Cool
Ranch Doritos from now on vegan friendly
but hey if you like to support the show
go to our patreon patreon.com trash
taste also follow us on Twitter send us
a memes on the subreddit and if you hate
our face listen to us on Spotify and uh
yeah I guess we'll we'll see you guys
next time sorry sorry if we get put any
uh trauma into you in terms of the
things we talked about yeah all right
well we'll see you guys next week
foreign
[Music]